What this episode is. Ladies
and gentlemen, if you, if
you tune into this podcast,
he go, oh, I'm going to elicit
to an intellectual discussion.
This is going to be fascinating.
No,
this is four guys sitting around
watching the UFC and we might get drunk.
Okay. Brendan Schaub is
here. Brian Cowan is here.
Aubrey Marcus is here and I'm here.
And what we did,
we decided to do is while the fights are
going on, we're in my podcast studio.
We figured, fuck it man. Let's watch the
fights with friends. Have a good time.
Have a cookbook.
Gag Dale's a couple of adult beverages.
I brought some 2003 Bordeaux.
Did you really? Where is it?
I'll put it into my class. I don't want a
real glass. Well, you'll learn. Oh, you,
they call me the aristocratic
for a reason. Anyway,
so if you look in for a regular
podcast with skip, oh look,
I've got a million of them,
but this ain't one of them.
This may not ever happen again,
but it's happening right now. Uh,
shop and Cowan and I talked
about doing this for awhile.
Aubrey just happens to be in town right
now. So, uh, we're doing it right now.
We're watching the,
uh, the prelims and uh,
no sponsors well were sponsored by on it.
Go to [inaudible] dot com o n n I t and
get your freak on. Use the Codeword Rogan
still waiting for you to fucking
email me your address. I clowned.
Email it to me. You fucking clown. I mean,
I'm not telling you did I told you?
Email it to me so I can email to
RB. Oh yeah, I'll get right on the
[inaudible]. [inaudible] it's so hard to
email people and it's almost impossible.
One piece of writing for my best
little yellow pad that just want to do
kettlebell workout. Right?
He doesn't care about mine.
Piece of paper.
You should have seen Brian trying to
pull back a 90 pound bow the other day.
He told me
things have ever seen. He tells me it's
all in tech. It's all in the technique.
Oh yeah. I saw that technique of
lifting weights for many years,
so shut up.
I wasn't warmed up. It was
so sad. My back. Anyway,
he needs kettlebells. Aubrey,
he needs a lot of things,
but kettlebells are also on the man.
I don't know if he wants one.
Yeah,
I want the Chevy doesn't want no man.
Maybe if he has it earlier today,
the, the, the main fights cost of was
good fight versus Lauren's locker.
That's the combien. Uh, Eric Koch is
a, is fighting on this car as well.
Let me pull it up on ufc.com which
a ufc.com is a very good website,
but the UFC app,
boy does that suck a fat one.
That is a fucking terrible app.
Whoever made that APP,
how dare you call positive a very,
that's a very good fight.
Eric Koch versus Dan Crookshanks.
Very good fight and Cruickshank,
who's, who's his last opponent,
he's so fun to watch. Oh yeah,
no shit man. Darren is a,
he's a taekwondo taekwondo
guy. Originally. He's got
wild ass fucking kicks,
but he's also like putting
together the rest of his game.
Now you might have the best
nickname in sports. What is it?
Detroit superstar was a little long.
No,
it's dope.
They should be shorter.
Creepy takes it from me. That's
pretty good. A little creepy.
That Detroit superstar. It's not a buy
my name be. If I was a fighter, Brian,
the irritable, irritable, he wouldn't,
when he doesn't eat, he gets
grumpy. Callen you really
wouldn't have a nickname.
No. No. What do you mean
I have, I need a nickname.
You'd be the kid need Brian.
Brendan Schaub gala.
Mike Rio was the,
the last fight. God Damn, that was a
good fight. She's the Mike Rio Fight. Uh,
Darrin Cruickshank was
on fire. Kicks, right.
He's laying a lot of kids
whose land and everything.
He just looked sensational and
coke's a bad mother fucker. Dude.
You know coke is a,
he's a very talented kid.
I mean he lost to a poor.
Yay.
But then he came back and beat Hafi
Elo. Oliveira he lost too, right?
He lasted a poor. Yay. And
then he lost. Lost Him. Ricardo
Lamas back to back. Yeah,
but too tough fucking guys.
Two really tough guys.
Why did you pour this in the glass? You
made sure you poured it in glass. Well,
it tastes better in a glass
coffee mug. The, the, the
blue. Shut up. Shut your mouth,
bring it to your nose. Shut your fucking
mouth. Take it into your mouth. Hey,
next year, see Eddie, Eddie
Wineland lost today. I know.
Got knocked up by this kid who was
caught in two years. First round.
I believe it was the second round.
I think he's the end of the first.
Could am I crazy? It might've been. I
was watching it while I was working out.
So you might be, who is the guy lost
to? Uh, I'll tell you right now.
I have a computer, but a Wineland.
I mean, coming off of a title fight,
right. You know, uh, it
comes off of that fight.
Then look sensational in his next
fight. He fights. I'm just get caught.
He fought eve job, Wayne and stopped him
and looked fucking sensational. Not well.
He fights in a weird way.
He Wineland keeps his,
never lifts his hands above his nipples.
Aggressive too. Super aggressive,
super strong. And he's a really good
fighter. He moves his head a lot.
He's got a lot of faints
and he gets away with it.
And the punches come from all kinds of
crazy angles because his hands are low,
but that's never a good style.
It's just never a good stock.
Keep your fucking hands low is never good.
And this kid correct him.
Johnny Eduardo cracked him with the
right hand and the first round. Um, yeah,
you were right. Round one, four minutes,
37 seconds in Brown one caught him with
a right hand earlier in the round and
then stunned him with one for about four
minutes 20 in and then followed up with
another one and dropped him in his legs.
Just completely gave out.
He's always that guy who is one away
from the title just in that weight class.
He's always,
he's always right there,
especially when he's there coming off
that eve job wave five where he looked
close fucking sensation and Jill boys
up, bad motherfucker dude, that was,
that was a really good fight. And
Eddie what? What rank number four?
I think so it's close number four
when exactly. He's number four.
He takes his fight against an unheralded
guy who hasn't fought in over two
years. This kid hadn't fought in.
I think it was something crazy,
like 700 days.
God said,
God a man top.
That's where it doesn't
pay to take fights.
Yeah, you're right. You're right. Well,
a lot of guys sit down and people give
him a hard time and they said, Ooh,
fighters fight.
But
man, it's a business. You should have
a manager. Listen, UFC Austin a fight.
I take it. But at the same time too,
you want to fight the highest rank guy,
the most famous guy possible.
That's all anyone cares about me.
And the highest rate guy
who'd ever turned down.
Have you ever turned
down and why? Um, man,
the only fight I ever turned down, it
was once, I don't remember his name.
He a huge guy. A grappler. Abu
Dhabi fight, peewee Herman.
Last few Herman fight of the
night. You know, I'm talking about,
but he retired enormous dude.
MMM. God dammit. Okay, let's Dave Herman
pull it up.
The Rock.
He really sweats a lot. Is that the guy?
Okay, I sweats. Last guy who sweats a lot,
man, I forget his name. God
super muscular. And My, my,
my manager called me and uh, with the
fight and I was like, uh, oh, John, olive,
Imo, Imo, Imo. So they
called me the fight and uh,
I just got off fight Nogueira so I'm
not going to go no gear. I know, right?
I was just like, no man, not happening.
And uh, my manager's like, well,
let's see what they come with. I said,
all right, well if it's a do or die,
I'll take it. Let's do
it. I'll destroy this guy.
And then they came up with a different
opponent, came up with Rothwell,
but that's the only fight where I
was like, ah, I don't think so man.
Right. Yeah. The only time, yeah. It's
a tricky thing, right? Like when you,
you want to take a fight if you're,
you know, if you need a fight,
if you need the money,
you want to take a fine.
But if you're in a situation where they
offer you something dangerous on two
weeks notice,
yes.
Like sometimes cards fall apart and
they try to pull that car together.
Like they're making a bunch of calls
this week to try to get someone to fight
Vitorin Brazil because junior
dos Santos just broke his hand.
Junior dos Santos was supposed to fight
Steve Bay chick, he broke his hand. Um,
they had meo chick is now gone.
Fabulous Maldonado who is at two oh
five or who's fan at two oh five true.
You know,
and now he's stepping up to
fight heavyweight and Steve
Bay Myoshia cause a top
10 guy.
So it's a,
it's kind of a crazy matchup that probably
wouldn't be approved in the state.
I agree. And I also heard that you can
get your money back. Oh wait. Why would,
why wouldn't that fight the, are you
sure? I heard the states like what?
There's actual five or fighting a top
10 heavyweight as a commissioner that
says that's just too much of a mismatch.
Well not even a two oh five or two or
five or that's been zombied you know,
I mean, he's been beaten senseless by
a bunch of guys. He's a tough mother.
Fucks as tough as they come.
Fabio Maldonado
is so tough that you got to watch out
for him if he fights a big guy because
he's got to go, God, this guy takes so
much punishment. He's so fucking tough.
You've got to almost protect
them from the other end though.
I can see cause Steve Bay has in the past
don't you rung because he is a beast.
Used to be a trading part in mine. Super
Freak to athlete to monster. However,
when he fought strew if he kind of gassed
out and got knocked out, correct. Yeah.
Now in this fight, you know what I
mean? The cardio, it could be an issue.
And uh, Fairview auto boxing
is really, really good. Yes.
He's got the most rabid fans in
the world driving him. That's true.
We watched him in Brazil and
they'd go crazy for five year.
Well Maldonado was just as tough as
the heroes. Toughest. Fuck man. He's,
and he's probably one of the
best body punches in this sport.
My concern would just be the size, just
the sheer size difference. What is Tbi?
Walk around at two 30. So who this
right now, who's fighting right now,
and Jane will give us some volume so we
can at least hear it. Hearing it is fine.
Chris Kerry Yasso and who is he fighting?
They'll give us some volume.
Bruce buffer with the official
introduction. Yeah, and
that's the coolest.
The coolest fucking thing is watching
Bruce buffer introduced fighters in Brazil
because everybody together goes,
it's really 2000 people
will be doing it in sync.
No Way. Oh, it's amazing. It's one of the
coolest things ever is actually great.
He's got that great voice. Ooh. Bruce
buffers the bat. He really is the best,
the best Bruce buffer.
I've seen him at Gold's gym.
I work out there in the off season.
I saw him in Gold's gym on the
cable machine doing the Bruce.
What was it? The one 80 turn though?
No, it works it out. You worked it out
and so explosive. I didn't see him
and I'm walking through the gym.
I hear [inaudible].
I was so embarrassed. Oh, that's funny.
He's good though. He doesn't
take, he doesn't have a a
card with them or anything.
He just remembers it all. That's not true
at all. He has a card constantly. Shit,
what are you talking about?
He reads off the cards.
He throws the cards in the ground
when he's done. Good Jack Ass.
Get your facts right. I was talking
about the rock again. Shit. By the way,
all you can't. They get mad
at me for giving Brian a
hard time. Do you know what?
I'd love this motherfucker like a brother
and I would give them a hard time if
it was a podcast or no pot.
That's how friends hang with.
He took a sensitive for me.
Thank you everybody. Thank
you. A marathon by the way.
He'll do that to me too. Okay.
That's what friends are all about.
It's not in the podcast. Joe Rogan, I
just don't have as many weaknesses as him,
so it's more difficult to find holes.
That's openings,
but if he finds holes in my game,
he will chip at them.
One of the things that friends are for,
I liked the USA keep each other honest.
We've got a good friend keeps sending
to jump on board. What's that?
USA judo jumping on board.
Just restaurants or shun?
Well USA recipe for what? Yeah, it is.
You'll see wrestles beings and I feel
like when you kick to the body with your,
with the top guys are fighting.
No, it did say that last thing.
I want to fight with them. When you kicked
your butt, when you kick to the body,
when the top of your foot,
I always feel like that's so risky because
you could break the top of your foot.
So we shut the fuck man.
We're talking taekwondo.
Not well. You know I broke the top of
my foot many times on elbows. Yeah,
that's what you gotta be. You
gotta be scared. But look,
obviously you could break
your fucking shins, your mind,
everything lightening fast. Cause
I go, I go up and then I can't,
you see Tyrone Spong brings lay against
fucking bill con Saki. Holy Shit. No,
I didn't see. It's weird
seeing a high level kickboxer
do that. It's a super rare.
I agree. But to me it's surprising that
not more guys break their legs. It is,
well, it's weird. There's like this rash
of broken legs. You know, Anderson Silva,
Tyrone Spong civil last week looking
pretty good, moving pretty good.
Well, Tyrone Spong is only four weeks
out. I think he's already walking.
He's walking on a treadmill. No CAS, no
nothing. They've got a bolt in there.
When you, what, what they do now back
in the day when you break your Femur,
I'll break your bone in half like that.
They would keep you off it.
What they do now is within 12 hours,
24 hours,
they tried to get you walking on it
immediately. And the reason for that,
they'll set it and have you actually start
putting pressure on it because to the
Bot,
what they found is it you heal faster
because your body rushes calcium to that
part of the bone and that
weird, that is weird. Within
12 hours, 12 hours, 12 hours.
Like if you were walking on a broken leg
and 12 obviously you don't put, yeah,
you don't put a lot of,
you don't put a lot of pressure,
but when they break their femur skiers,
they got those guys in their feet as
soon as possible because apparently you
know the, you, you heal
much faster. Wow. Yeah.
So Carrie also is a,
he's a wild mother fucker man.
I love watching their kid fight too. And
now that he's dead, this is one 25 right?
These guys are fighting at one 25 or are
they not a fly wakes 25 cause he fought
at one 35 for the longest time
and he was kind of undersized.
I'm glad they have
that. They're, you know,
they're thinking about doing a straw
weight. A one 15 for guys and for women's.
Obviously they are. But for
guys there Straw weight, man,
that is a small dude.
That's right.
That would be such a nightmare to fight
that guy because he'd probably still win
and he's so respectful. I box with that
Guy Wayne McCullough. He light you up.
I know him. You kidding me?
Worst thing ever. It just
takes so much longer. One 19.
Oh, what's like Ken and Floy and
you see Kenny flew into a bar,
probably going to pick on it. Yeah,
I'll let it says dresses like a hipster,
although he's hitting the
baddest dudes on the planet.
But both my head and your head would fit
in Kenny's head. He's got a giant head,
big head, huge head. When I
first saw him in person, I went,
that can't be Kenny Florida.
And that's the biggest head I've
ever seen on that gentleman. And uh,
I wonder if there's a real
direct correlation between
taking a punch and having
a big head. I always joke around about
it and talk about it in podcasts. Well,
boxing boxing trainers thing, Emmanuel
Steward said that they look for when,
when trainers looking for boxers, they
look for a wide face and a short neck.
We'll look at David [inaudible] who
took a punch better than that Guy
[inaudible] Nelson mark
on Roy Nelson. Yeah. Yeah.
And then there's some guys that just
like Tommy Hearns always had a hard time
taking a punch.
Just has that narrow face.
And there's nothing you can do about that.
Just it is what it is.
You want to talk about a guy spinning?
So I'm fucking wars. Tommy Hearns.
I was watching some Tommy Hearns fight.
The other guy on Youtube,
a couple when he knocked out Duran Dude,
he knocked around and he was and he
was and he fought at 47 which I can't
believe. Yeah, well he fought
as high as a light heavyweight.
I believe he went all the loss to Iran.
Barkley.
I think that was at one 68 I'm not sure.
You know what's interesting about this
fight is a, usually you have to have,
so for instance, homeboy on the
cages, red shorts, car Yasso. Yes.
And the other guy is black and red shorts.
Both similar shorts usually have
to be complete opposite shorts.
They force you to do that. Yeah. It's
just the bottom of the trim though.
It's pretty obvious, isn't it? You think?
I think it go cut. This guy, the guy,
um, what's Carrie asked? Mocha
Curiosa. No, he's a morning Thai guy.
Caught on using that term is
try to dope dope response.
First of all your word.
Don't let Rhonda tell him some moves.
She my favorite word though. How are
we go? She is, Oh shit. Oh it's tight.
Oh nope. Lost the position.
But I'll let go of that.
Getting a lot of guys who've been
catching that von flue choke. Yeah man.
Cause they hang on the routine.
Look at this. He gets forward again.
It does not under the Chin though. He's
just a that crank and I'm, yeah. Nice.
Oh Nice fish.
Then the round scrappy,
crappy end of the round lolly
guys hang onto that key.
A teen and then all the guys
doing is taking them down.
Pass the side control and you can't get
your glove out. You know what I'm saying?
Can't you? Your glove out. So
then you have a choke there.
You just ramming your shoulder
into the artery and the, yeah,
they can't get it out. It's called
the von flue choke. That's what, uh,
everybody calls it because someone just
had a big finish with that recently.
Now OSP crew. Yeah. Opens
saying against Al Capone,
a guy who was fighting and heavyweight
most of his career, really undersized.
A smallest heavyweights ever.
Yeah.
He's fighting a Cody Donovan in Dublin.
Now I OSP is a no,
a alcopop two oh five hmm.
Interesting that that von flue choke.
You very rarely see in Jujitsu though.
That's what's interesting about that.
Jitsu guys don't a good GC guys not gonna
hang onto that. Yeah, he's just not,
it's true.
They're not going to waste the energy.
High level juice guys don't go
waste his energy on it's up.
The guy was kind of panicking in a fight
and a fight gets taken down and doesn't
want the guy to posture,
so he holds onto the gay thing and
then when your gloves caught in there,
you're screwed. Man. It's a
lot of pressure. I mean, I'm
sure you felt it. You know,
with a glove on. It's a different story
when you're stuck. It's like, Dang. Yeah.
When a guy really knows how
to put that weight on it too,
he's got a good side control
and knows how to pin you down.
Put forced that shoulder and your neck
or yeah, you'd to sleep. Some guys
can fuck you up. Just head arm control
when they're passing your card,
like there's different kinds of pressure.
It's like his wrestler pressure.
There's some guys straight on top of you.
They just,
they know how to put all their weight
on a very small point like this.
Some guys who get side control on you,
but they're like laying on their knees
and even if they're cy controls solid.
If you can't get out of it, you're
not hurting, you're not in pain.
And then there's other motherfuckers that
we'll have all of their weight unlike
the left side of their chest and they'll
like put side control on you. Just
where do you like a collage of science?
Yeah, it really is. It's a balance.
I'm still working on it.
It's hard, man. It's hard.
It's interesting because I have like
a nasty twister side control on,
on the right side,
but then when I do it on the left side,
it feels alien because I never go to it
on the left side of some positions like
that. It's, we're,
we would think that this is a position I
know in my head inside and now it's not
that complex a position, but on the
right side, Bam. It's like, I'll fuck,
it's like a clamp bank. It's
like locked in place. But on the,
on the other side I'm like
moving too much and I'm slippery.
It was,
people could see Joe because he's actually
moving around in his chair wiggle.
I'm a wiggler. He's a wiggle in this
corner. No wiggle. I'm a wiggler Brian,
Kaitlyn and Brian Callen number. We, are
you ever going to go back to Jujitsu? Um,
I think I'd like to talk about on the
ride down and I miss it a lot and then he
goes, well everyone has nick problems
who does Jujitsu. That is true.
A lot of people do.
You're a big guy. Yeah,
it's the real problem is rolling with
big guys. Don't roll big guys stacked.
Getting stacked is a big
problem and exploding,
trying to explode from the bottom.
A lot of times guys get injured doing
that bridge. Going to be smart. Brian,
you're not trying to win Abu Dhabi.
Just grapple with girls. Only when,
when?
When Brian and I first met each other,
I brought him to Carlson Gracie's and he
started working out with Sergio Cohen.
It was one of Carlson Gracie's black
belts and he like grabbed Sergio's neck.
Well because I was grabbed his neck,
like Claude is never going into a Sergio
headbutted him and his nose and broke
his nose and just smushed him
like a bug because I was actually,
I went in there like thinking as a
wrestler I was going to take these,
I was taking like people
down because they've,
they don't care about that may limit. Let
me clarify, this is not what happened.
He,
he just got aggressive and Douchey with
a guy who was a big juiced up crossing
gate.
That guy,
I mean he's a big guy to
play to watch that. Yeah.
I didn't have any respect cause I
thought out this is the wrestling bad
wrestling. I didn't know where that
meat head, who's going all hard.
I was just taking, I would like they'd
white belts and they're like blue belts.
Who'd never done any rustling,
so I'd be taking them down and then I
go third year. Who Decides to go, let's,
let's do some you want to take,
you want to go take downs?
And he grabs me and I was like,
oh well that's a bear.
And it was so much bigger than
him. Okay, now we're back.
We're back to Fox sports one. Everybody,
the fights were on Fox sports too.
And then what happened? The the base guy
handles over. So we'll get back to you.
We'll get back to my fighting. That
bullshit baseball game. What was it? Nine.
Nothing forces us to baseball.
If they invented baseball today,
people would spit in your face
and we tried to sell it. I agree.
If you try to pitch and given one bill,
why I got a gain,
it'd be could take forever.
It's like fucking like cricket.
Imagine trying to pitch cricket.
Oh, oh, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Why is he throwing the ball like that?
What is he doing? Why does he have a pet?
Your arm is your arm on? He has a
paddle wheel. The guy has a paddle.
And why is this game lasting three days?
You can read the fucking guy is
nick it and make it go backwards.
And where is the game? Last
three days. No satisfaction.
Even if you whacked the ball
hard. And guess what? In baseball,
if you hit the ball three out of 10
times, you're in the hall of fame. Yup.
Three out of 10 guess what? In the
UFC, when three out of 10 flights,
you don't know,
three out of 10 10 cracks
him with a nice left car.
Yasso throws a very deceptive head
kick to he. He hides his head kicks.
Well he'll sneak him over the outside
of the shoulders like the right outside,
right over the Jag. It's
fucking Deontay wilder. Yes.
Beat the fuck Internet troll classic.
The guy he fought, first of all,
that guy who the troll is insane. Like
clinically, something's wrong with him.
Like he's like bipolar or something.
I want him to knock the
troll out like really bad.
The troll had me laughing because it
took a shot during the gym and he takes a
shot and hit some of the
body and then they're like,
break it up and then the troll just
goes, got you to the body, bro. Hit you,
hit you the body man body,
and they went back at it and while
they're crushed him, smashed him,
got him on the ground, dropped
him, hit him when he was down.
He still like hit you in the body. I
hate that. Made me laugh because I know
he's going to sleep. He's got a
power game going to sleep. Oh,
he's trying to get out of it.
That's a good way to get out of it.
Guys do get out of it that way.
Just drop into their back. Wow.
He got right there. That right
there. That's how you hurt
your neck. That is how I,
my fucking neck has gotten hurt so many
times because I didn't tap and I'm like,
boom, fucking no Turpin I'm
no to happen. Meanwhile,
your neck is ruined for weeks if you
just have that ego. I don't have that.
If I'm going with another UFC heavyweight,
if we're trained together,
I'm not tapping and then not had
enough that he got no. However,
if I'm at the Gracie Academy
up, man, I don't care. Do not.
The idea is that you shouldn't have been
in that position in the first place.
You know how to learn from it.
You're going to learn from it and UFC.
If you're a heavy weight,
you have to be under to 60 right to 65
to 65 somebody was saying that there is a
purpose, there is a, there is a number,
there's a perfect way for a heavyweight,
two 42 42 in other words,
that's where the best guys
seem to lie at [inaudible].
Even if you would let made the weight
class 300 and you got a 300 pound guy,
well the differences in boxing,
in boxing,
it's a little lighter because
you don't get it got away on you.
Like you have to deal with the fact that
you're moving bodyweight around. Right?
Like there's a different way like
in boxing look at, in my opinion,
Mike in his prime,
the Mike Tyson of the early, the
like the 85 Mike Tyson, that range.
I think he's the greatest heavyweight
of all time. That's my opinion.
Just a lot of the people that have
opinions, but I think the Mike Tyson,
the destroyed Marvis Frazier,
the Mike Tyson that knocked out Larry
Holmes to 20 to 20 maybe two eight just
Hauer mother fucking guys
just motherfucking them. Yeah,
but I don't think you could get
away with that as a UFC fighter.
I don't think in boxing, by the way,
doesn't even have a fucking wait Mendez.
He would have been what?
Two S two too small to handle a big guy
on top of them that they'll guy like
Cain takes you down,
lays on you and starts.
You got a guy like big foot
who's capturing 300 men.
You're talking about a different game.
It's always funny to me and granted,
listen, cutting weight.
I'm sure it's horrendous.
I've cut from two 50 to 25 for
Metamorris and it was tough,
but not like these guys. You know, Bacon,
one 55 one 45 but we'll be at the
wanes and nothing drives me more crazy.
Everyone goes, God wish I was a
heavyweight. Everyone tells that English.
How's everybody?
Oh do you?
Oh really? That's cool. You're fighting
a guy at one 55 right? That's cool.
Because I weighed two 38
the guy I'm fighting to 65
I'm scared shitless. 25 pounds
a lot of ways. A lot of weight.
25 25 almost 25 men.
25 with 16 ounce John
Stacked on top each other.
And then that drops on your head.
Just that is that two weight
classes pretty much. And there's,
there's no other division like that
and said there's nothing like that.
This guy keeps giving his neck to carry
off. So carry also on the bottom here.
You're right.
You know the,
the shorts are confusing cause I just
thought [inaudible] was on the bottom.
I've never seen it this close.
Usually Yossi doesn't play that game.
You know, you're fighting a
superstar if they're like, yeah,
he got some black shorts. Oh, okay. Make
you cool. Change the color of your shirt,
you're wearing white. He's obviously
when the Croatian flag black. Cool man.
Nobody ever had to worry about that.
With rich Franklin,
he's got the pink shorts and you can
have your Brown oh carrier Aso's mounted.
Oh Shit.
Smokers on top of him.
Did you guys see the Zak Cummings
fight earlier tonight? No.
Fucking incredible fighter and credible.
What a fight. It was awesome. Yeah.
And Cummings was the underdog
and he wound up winning.
I don't think mount is
a dangerous positions.
Everyone thinks as it's notoriously known
for. What do you think of that, Joe? Um,
I think in MMA the,
the problem with the mount is
when you go to rain down punches,
you give up space.
And when you give up space,
guys put their hands on your
hips and they pop softly.
Like people think when you get to
mount, like, oh no, it's over now.
Especially if a guy knows what he's doing,
depending on the mound posture. But,
but if you're, if you have your
hooks in, you control them,
you're not going to go to punches hard.
Well,
some guys have a nasty Malik Benevidez
has a wicked mount because he does,
he does a guard from the mount. I
love that position. And when, uh,
when you Mount Guy and you cross
your feet underneath his body,
you can constrict him the same way you
can with a guard and Benevidez if he gets
a, uh, an arm anywhere near your chin,
his gay teen game is so strong as,
as your,
I favors as his cello Mendez.
All the teen guys are
ridiculous when they get unit.
I'm just saying as far as taking punishing
them, if you have a decent amount,
dark defense guys are evenly matched.
Scramble. This is a great
Jujitsu match actually. Yeah.
There used to be a time where mouth
or like back mount was game over.
People got used to that.
It's like for like five years.
Is that all you've got his back.
It's a similar thing.
Like so gets a mountain even
in even a camp right now.
So I want to get to mountain
was like, oh no. And I was like,
well do you remember when big of a deal
rem co Pardot fought Marco who was Marco
who has mounted him and he tapped
sheer terror. You've got
the mountain. He's like,
he says over the position is no Gui.
You know what one guy where if he got
mount it was actually over and you should
tap shank Carlin. Oh
yeah, that's a good point.
And it's like having a building on it
didn't matter how good your Jujitsu,
we haven't a building on you,
but Brock Lesnar survived it.
Otherwise Way Shankar strong.
Scott Bardelli any postured up Dan
Carlin's strongest guy you've ever,
ever rolled with? Yes. I mean he's like,
he's like an alien from a muscle planet.
You don't want to say it's like,
Oh did you come from muscle planet?
That fucking guy was so big and his arms
were so long to get my car and cry man.
After practice you'd think
you'd be getting better.
Cause he takes like a week off cause
he just didn't give a shit. Yeah.
And then I'd beat,
you know,
in the gym and electric in the gym seven
days a week he'd come in and just what
my ass now when he got injured,
you know, like what, how,
how much did his injuries progress
and how did they progress?
Cause I know he had a lot of
back injuries, back injuries,
then they had a horrible neck and it
was like, like when he fought Frank Mir,
he might've hit myths three times.
He just couldn't do it. Wow.
We just got fucked up when, when
Shane, Colin flat, Gabriel Gonzaga,
that was like his very first big test
and he knocked them out with like, uh,
like this.
He just went boom and knock Gabriel's
and after you got tagged and he got his
nose broken. Exactly. But, uh,
when Shane was getting me for that fight
and I've seen a ton of fighters, man,
my time a ton,
the best in the world,
that was the best heavyweight
and I've ever seen in my life.
She was about two 55 sure.
Ratted.
It looked like you shaved a silverback
gorilla and put boxing gloves on them.
And I had to be his main training.
I like,
I had to give myself a pep talk in
the car. I was talking myself up like,
you can do this bro, just get,
just get through it. Yeah. But I,
I've never, his speed, his
quickness, his cardio was good.
He hit so hard and they'd be like,
Hey, we got other guys for Shane today.
I'm like, thank God cause I don't
have to go one round with them.
These other guys would go in.
I'd just sit back and like,
you would knock everybody out, man. In
training, in training now. Did at grudge,
was there too much of that
going on at grudge? Uh,
I would say yes.
Big Smile before you answer, I
would say. But you know what,
that was the thing that like back
then I think every gym was like that.
Cause I go to for you knew better before
you go down to Jackson's and all we
would do is punch each other in the face.
It's all we did.
It's a weird thing because a lot, you
know who criticizes a lot of that is um,
Ernesto hoost or nuts. So who's who's
talking about gyms that do that?
And he was like, it's ridiculous.
It's horrible because it's very,
doesn't make you better. It's
not necessary. It doesn't
make you what's doing it.
It's taken yet it's taken out
potential fight of the nights.
You could have getting paid a lot of
money for it. Like a on Friday. Um,
it's spined at rain and
there's a bunch of new guys.
They're tough high level guys.
And if they don't have headgear on,
I won't smarm really
nothing cause my head.
But if we both can you cut my list, man,
I got to fight in four weeks. Right.
Beating you up does nothing for me. I
don't get paid to do this. Well they,
they were wondering why it's like that
now I'll say something like, Nah Bro,
get headgear, we'll do it. We'll go
next round our role or something. Right.
They did it really?
And somebody was talking about how smart,
when somebody gets knocked out five times
or whatever and they start getting a
glass chin, so you
touch them, they go out.
And what they were saying was that the
reason for that was that your brain, when,
when you, when you get caught, you're
brain will shut off. It's so used to that.
It goes, oh danger time, don't
want any more punishment.
Gotta protect itself and we'll
shut your body right off. The Dell,
Dell explained it to me.
We were talking about at once and he
said that he just couldn't take a shot
anymore. What it was because he
said he was, you know, he was,
he would grit his fucking,
it would bite down on his mouthpiece and
cough it out and just absorb punishment.
And his brain knew when he was getting
hint that he was going to do that and his
brain knew that he was gonna absorb
punishment. So the is like, fuck you,
I'm going to just shut off.
That's good though. Yeah.
So when I said somebody who can be the
point of you and I'm telling the story
again. All right, so that's right. Yeah.
Johnny Hendricks came out pretty publicly
and talked about how he didn't take
head shots for that whole camp
against Lawler. Well it's smart.
You see him in the cage there and those
guys are just trading back and forth.
Then you got to save it for when
it counts you football, don't they?
They're not going to see,
they don't scrimmage like
all these certain guys cause
they're getting smarter.
Like Michigan, Ohio state, they
don't hit during the season.
It makes in the NFL you really don't hit,
you don't hit your paying these athletes
so much money. Why the hell listen,
if you can't take a punch
now or void a pinch now,
you're not going to do it four weeks from
now. Exactly. That's a very good point.
And your ability to take a punch a lot
of times depends on how many punches
you've already taken. I mean, we've
all seen guys where they just,
their chin starts to go.
We've all seen guys like that
where they just start to hit.
Did you see Pat Barry's last fight?
I did.
Pat Barry had never gotten knocked out
before. When he fought Chuck Congo,
check Congo was the first time he
ever went out. That was a great fight.
It was a great fight. But then he
got knocked out there. He got knocked
out by soul politely.
He got knocked out by Lavard Johnson.
He got knocked out and he got knocked
out by this Zach Movie Casa. Holy Shit.
Is that guy up to hell? What was that?
That's the Congo son. That's a girl.
Grew up in the fucking Congo.
Congo.
We we're talking about when we
were talking about Russians,
Russians are scared of people from the
Congo cause that's some next level shit.
Next level shows dudes who climbed,
he's got silver backs in Russia,
the wrestling,
grizzly bears. Here I am in Malibu
playing grab ass with Bruce Jenner.
How the fuck am I going to do
this, man? My kids are screwed.
So I kick a Jaguar in the,
I
kick his shuck water, I DVR
it. And when I got home,
I fast forward to Pat Barry's fight in
the dude. He was fighting. I was like, no,
who signed this fight? Why would
you do that? Movie Casa has a,
he's got a pretty good boxer boxing
background. Yeah. And you know,
I think it was 12 and one is a pro.
I like Pat Barry.
But I hate when a guy says
I fight one round fights.
So I fired one round fired some other.
If I wonder if I stop,
we stop saying that it's a mental week.
Well not only that, like what do you,
I understand that you want to be exciting.
I understand that.
But you're a fighter and you're skillful.
You know that guy should be doing and
he should be training at some high level
camp, you know, some high level Moitai.
Can you want to be a more anti fighter?
Fucking go to Golden Glory MMA gym.
Go Do. Yes, exactly. Go somewhere.
You know how was the guy who had walked
into wrestling and literally you'd be
like, dude, just don't kill
your dog on the way here.
Or You'd get to watch wrestling and
just be like super sad, super sad.
The other heavyweight shop go
with pat and like, all right,
come here and Mopey Murdo let's go.
Let's go.
This is how you avoid
hitting stuffed on your back.
He just hated wrestling that much.
Hate, dreaded it. He was gone.
He was doing wrestling and was like, you
know what? Fuck this. And then was like,
I'm, I'm, I'm retiring. I don't wanna
do this anymore. That's hilarious. Hear.
I hear he's like a really funny guy.
Like he's hilarious. He's a great guy,
but for how much longer?
How much longer?
If he keeps getting knocked out like
that, you know? That's what I worry about.
I like that. It's a sweetheart. He's
a great guy. He's tough as shit.
He puts on exciting fights. I mean,
when he knocked out the late, great,
Shane del Rosario, that was like one, a,
one of my favorite heavyweight fights
ever. Yeah. I'll take some more.
You're not mad at this wine, by
the way. Very. I'm not mad at this.
Bulletproof coffee.
The only reason I come,
somebody is in camp. I swill line
like an aristocrat. By the way,
it's one of the reasons why he
can't pull back in 90 pound ball.
Your body's rejecting. It doesn't matter.
I've got good taste buds. My buddies,
I'm belt for dancing,
elbows, whatever bullshit.
Afterwards I can do 28 champs,
which, okay, which is Peter,
tell me how to tell me. He's like, I
don't get it. You could do it so easy.
You could do it easy. By the way, heavy
weights. I was all bunched up. I was like,
Huh? Heavyweights. How about
pots was selling mouthpieces.
That's how he got into the game. Sell
mouthpieces, pots and sour politely.
[inaudible] he's not, he's not Samoan
isn't, how do you see he's a happy boy.
His name Ruan pots. Let's put some
volume here. Is He from Holland?
Where's he from?
Heavyweight comes to the UFC.
Haven't finished.
Let's back it up so we could see how
John Annex says his name and then fast
forward. So we're not out of line
with all the people watching at home.
So am I be besides big foot.
The second biggest guy
back it up again. What a bad
ass. I wish I was. Simone,
you'll see on the back it up again
and welcome to the big show.
Rule One.
Alright,
for this shit. Where is Ron pots
from? He lives next door to you,
your wife right now. Hey Man, I'll tell
you. I'm not there to videotape it.
What is this?
Why does Fox News insists on putting
hot chicks in dresses that talk about
sports? I'm not mad about it.
I'm not mad about it either,
but it makes me uncomfortable.
My Dick gets hard, right?
I'm watching. I'm like,
what are you doing?
Are you sending me mixed mixes and had
a big sweaty Samoan comes on the screen.
You're like, oh no, I'm really confused.
I disagree with your political outlook,
but my dick is hard listening.
Got a hard on.
I want to argue with you and give you
a better point than you're capable of
making.
Yeah.
Just so I can fuck. You
can remember on a freak,
your friends would just walk
into the room with a heart on.
Well that's what they're trying to do
when they're putting these women on Fox
News. I mean, look, not,
not saying there's anything wrong
with these women or that they're not
intelligent. They surely are.
That's how they got on you. Look,
it's very difficult to get a job where
you're a political correspondent or
you're doing sports.
I mean it's even harder for a woman
to do sports and it's for our man,
cause he's got to stand
up to all the patriarchy,
all the bullshit that guys don't want
to hear women talking about sports.
However, they're all hot. Like
that's a, that's a fucking strategy.
They know what they're
doing and you tricking us.
We can have large Marge
up there and be like,
let's just Wayne Wayne back that up real,
oh, packed that up. I need to see
this. There's no need for that.
When you think about a boner,
so here's the commercial is all
this Wayne Newton's spinning around.
That might be a wow.
Who's hot as fuck,
by the way,
is excited that we Newton still don't
let it let it roll because Oh and look,
she gets excited. No, she
knows that. Oh Gee, you're not
a good enough factor, ma'am.
You're not a good enough factor
for that to go to videos and face.
Zombie did touch her pussy moist. No, he
does not. He's a thousand years old. Yeah,
and I know you want to get your sag card,
but that's,
there's better ways vampires.
There's fucking better ways.
[inaudible] who's able to wink?
He had a fucking sweat.
You doing squats.
Weekend is like 40 pounds.
The Botox.
I bet he has so many bitches in Vegas.
It's not even books ridiculous.
He probably has so much money,
so if he has so much money,
of course he has so many bitches
in case there's so many lost,
confused people get these girls to
the show seeing some little song.
I think at this point in his career it's
probably done. I disagree. I disagree.
He's performing at Hooters casino though.
He is he.
Okay, well let's find out
where he is. Well, he might
still be, believe it or not,
either way and cause he's going,
he's going back to the villain.
Just haven't bitches. It's one of
those things like Tony Bennett.
Will you pretend it's good
if Tony Bennett between the spearmint
rhino or going to see Tony Bennett? Me,
it. No, because I just feel like
those girls, I feel sorry for them.
Most of them are nursing students. Wayne
newton.com schedule. Let's go to sketch.
You guys want to get boners in the
meantime or no? All right. Oh, okay.
He might not even be in Vegas anymore
because it says here he's in Nebraska,
five 17 Lindenwood university.
Yup.
Casino Dude. He took, he
took your shit on the road.
There's nothing wrong with that,
but it's not even defending Wayne Newton.
You're a contrarian,
but university is spelled wrong.
It's you never city cit. Why that's not
how you spell university isn't, well,
if it's a university, Brian, who
you got in this fight, heavyweight,
Samoan on principal,
Mr Las Vegas world tour and he's going
to some university in Saint Charles,
Missouri and then another
place in Wisconsin,
Lake Lake.
Of the torches resort.
Casino lock do Flom Bay,
Wisconsin.
Holy Shit. You know, he just,
he wishes Hooters casino. Wow.
He might not be in pain. This is
really true. He really does. He still,
he still calls himself Mister Vegas.
I don't know.
It's a good question man. It seems like
he's not in Vegas anymore. That's insane.
It's a shame. Really. So,
Brendan, for the heavyweights,
how much tougher is a heavyweights
chin versus the punching power?
Like what's that relation there? You
people ask me this all the time. I mean,
besides Mark Hunt and Roy Nelson,
there's really no such thing. Everyone's
been knocked out at heavyweight.
I mean name a guy,
he's been knocked out.
All the top guys have really been
knocked out. So, and if you haven't,
you're not finding tough enough guys.
Yeah.
So if you say from
middleweight to heavyweight,
how much more of a punch does it take?
20% 30% it's tough to say Tufts.
It depends on the fighter. But like
if a soul, it lands a good jab here,
it could knock at that size of a jab,
the size of his legs.
So saw my God,
Brian, please control, sorry. Sorry. It's
a big boy. He's put your back straight.
But I'm just saying so it was a big
boards a hands, Huh? But he fought, he,
he felt part of against Eddie Sanchez
in his first fight in the UFC,
just hardier adrenaline,
adrenaline dump because Ryan Parsons
was very high on this guy who was saying
like, the guy's a beast. He
just, he just had a hard time.
He's light on a hard time
dealing with the pressure.
The pressure's a motherfucker,
right. I mean, oh Brendan,
you feel like the pressure was
you sold on so yeah, exactly.
Doing saying guys do that drives
me nuts. But Paul, Ellie, his,
he had his arm trapped, trapped. But
if it wasn't, he would come over.
But I bet he doesn't do that
cause he's not a graph. No. Well,
you know he did Mount,
um, Pat Barry. Pat. Yes.
So did my brother.
But he did work with a lot of wrestlers.
He did work with a raw. So
it did. So look at this.
This guy's using this gay teens to,
he's using.
Can you just gave him half guard so
it just, and then he gave it back.
He's still holding onto his neck. Look
at, Hey, roll the ball with the neck.
Oh my goodness.
This is some blue belt level shit is a
good thing for it to be a horrible idea.
But uh,
pulled guard,
Eh Brendan Schaub getting
crazy. Yeah. Not a good move.
What look what level of
Jujitsu when you compare,
like say Metamorris Abu Dhabi and then
you watch grappling like an average match
in the UFC. Give me some
volume there. Young Jamie,
how much a difference do you
think? What do you, what do you,
what would you say the average is like in,
in metamorris black belt in the U s level
black. The average. His purple belt.
I would really, I would say this
is blue belt. What we're seeing,
this is low level. Yes, this is blue belt,
but I think the [inaudible] I'd
say on average I'd say purple.
He's not as having an arm bar. The elbows?
No, no, he doesn't have that either.
I was saying it was in the family and the,
in that family.
Do you think the average is purple belt?
If you had, let's say, purple belt,
whatever about yeah, that's a pro
belt. And then when he went and then,
but at one 55 black belt.
Black belt. Yeah. Yeah.
One 55 one 70 oh Hellboy how fucking
good is Jim Miller's Jujitsu?
God Ron's out and see that cause
polarity hits fucking hardest shit man.
Had kissed him on the back of the head.
Wow. Where did he kiss the referee?
Yeah. Good move. Yeah. Keith
Peterson's a sexy bitch.
It's a good guy to kiss politely.
See now there's a guy that is getting
comfortable in the UFC and you're getting
to see what everybody saw from him in
the gym. Neon belly gets the mount.
Dang. Oh, oh no.
Even not even a lot behind it.
Oh, he kissed him. Yeah. Awesome.
Left underneath all that. Needed
them daily check out the left. Not,
but this is what everybody said about him.
The guy fucking hits wicked hard.
Look at this pump that left town and I
look at guys that one eye open. Oh God.
He's seeing all kinds of shit that you
used to see when you were a little kid.
When you saw those cartoons where a guy
got hit in the head with a frying pan.
I think I saw that in the jungle.
[inaudible]
we'll talk about that tomorrow.
So it's like 21 and three now I think.
Yeah. Impressive. [inaudible]
it's outside the UFC,
so I don't want to do the Haka
because I can only get behind it.
My favorite thing, I watched the all
blacks hoc all the time. I do it.
Am I going to be up? Yep.
Sorry for yourself. You
haven't a fucking pity party.
Well, no idea. Youtube with a Haka.
Nobody wants to be Samoan more than me,
so
I may or may not have written
my own Haka actually really
go to battle. Sorry sir. Swim across
the orange potion, the dugout canoes.
I realized that I couldn't do
anything with it, but I've tried.
It's all right man. So right. As
was motivated as far as that Haka,
I watched a lot of watch, a little cowl
Drogo game of Thrones. As far as Joe,
if you think Jujitsu, is
that okay? It approvable
level overall we're talking I'll
weight classes. What would you say?
Striking purple belt as well?
Probably would say, yeah,
I mean if you pay attention to
like look at high level boxing,
look at high level Moitai look at high
level kickboxing and the difference
between kickboxing and Muay Thai.
For folks who don't know,
if you watch him like glory,
what they're not allowed to do in glory
and I'd Love Glory but what they're not
allowed to do his elbows to the head
and the not allowed to clinch and throw
knees. But Moy Tai, that's a
big part of my time, a big,
and it also protects fighters and in a,
in a good instance,
a good a example rather a guy like
John Wayne par multiple time Moy Thai
champion,
but not really allowed to use his
full skillset when he fights in glory.
And I'm a fan of why is that?
Why?
Because Gloria has decided they
want to go to the k one route.
And what k one decided was they used
to let you clinch with two hands,
but then Alastair started
kneeing guys into oblivion.
So they changed two hands to one hand.
Sakharova yeah.
Could Sakharova fun with it? Oh No. It
was a who did he fight where he broke his,
his chin, uh, soccer.
Rob and broke his chin over him. Did it to
him. No, no Overeem. Never fought soccer.
I think you're thinking of Melvin
Manhoef. Nope. No fought soccer.
Rabo Sakuraba only in Muay Thai.
MMA.
He never fought when we tie it was MMA
booze in the clinch. He broke his chin.
Sorry, I just heard, I'm not
sure what fight that wasn't me.
Soccer Sakharova has taken some
fucking brutal beatings in his time.
But the bottom line is that you're,
you're not as able to defend yourself
if you're fighting kickboxing because
kickboxing, you have all these
other things that you can do.
You know you can grab the plum,
you can shove your head up into the
side of his head and really control that
clinch, a need of the body and
trip and throw him to the ground.
There's all these different
things that you could do.
Like you watch the only
promotion in America that
allows that as lion fights and
you can wash out an access TV.
Great, great, great fights.
I love watching that and you, you, we
see some really like high level Moy,
Tai, you see all the elbows,
you see the, the, there's,
there's all these tools that guys are
allowed to use and stand up an MMA that
you can't use and dream we can't or rather
a you can't use in k one and he can't
use in glory.
One of the most confusing things I ever
saw was watching fights in Bangkok and
similarly in Thailand because the rule
system there for the Muy Thai fight,
first of all it's epic cause their bet
everybody taught at that time like come
on the way though they will do like
in first round they'll a lot of times
because they bet on things like
how many, how many, uh, roundhouse.
Second I sort of the right side. They
do all kinds of stuff. You're a guy,
if you're betting on your guy,
your guy will get that notion.
He'll get that note and he'll actually,
so that you can never tell
how somebody's going to do,
how good a fight or somebody is by
watching their first round. Yeah.
There's a lot of times,
a lot of the best things in a
lot of guts came in after that.
But you would watch these
fights and there'd be some,
the crowd would go crazy
for a knee to the body,
like crazy for a need of the body or
kicked in the leg or something like that.
And then you'd see like an American
guy in their English guy, I don't know,
white guy in there and he would just
start like in late around just start
lighting somebody up with punches
to the face, like Hook, cross,
upper cut and you're like, oh shit.
Oh Shit. But I'm the only one yelling.
And then at the end of the fight I'm like,
man,
that guy kicked the other guys
as Joe and hit me. It's the,
it's the Thai guy who landed more knees
that when what is going not Sakharova
Fujita
No. Yeah, he got a plot. Overeem, Overeem.
What he did was kick was
nice. Yeah, it kicked,
that was Eddie Wineland
and he knocked out.
He's gonna Fight Tj Dillashaw such a
good back. Bacchic yeah, that's Hanan.
Barao he might be the best pound for
pound guy on the planet around phenomena.
Phenomenal. He's not the
best. He's close to it yet,
but I'm t j by Japanese necktie.
Oh yeah.
Maybe I wouldn't that be crazy though.
That'd be dope.
I showed it to him at the Onnit
headquarters. Did you really?
I couldn't believe you didn't
know it. Never seen it. No,
neither did a t TJ didn't know.
And Danny Castillo,
neither one of those guys knew it. Amun
Ra and the Japanese neck hold with them.
Yeah, well I showed them some techniques
that I, well the only tapping was uh,
that and then I just put them in
rubber guard and asked him to escape.
And then I got him in the M and Ari.
Do you know the MNR well,
I was trying to show Whitney. I don't know
the names to a problem. A lot of Bravo.
Well [inaudible] not Bravo's.
It's a and technique. It's a,
it's basically an Omoplata.
We finished with a neck crank.
You go for the Omoplata
when you got the guy,
you know how you got a guy flatten
down, you've got the seat belt. Yeah.
You grabbed the neck.
It's a fucking devastating move.
I'll pull it up for you to just
do it to me. No, I'll show you.
Just do it to me.
Well,
you can just voice gets
raspy my dick out on God.
The bone or is everywhere.
This podcast is the best,
but because Google uh,
imaginary all my plot,
a neck crank, there's a video of
it. It's pretty fucking dope dude.
He um, he really knows how to do it.
He and he invented that. Ever seen it?
I never saw anybody do it before.
Mnr He did.
We got some videos of you teaching that
on the, on it youtube too. Oh is that on,
on its youtube? I'm pretty sure.
Yeah. Better get audit. I asked,
I asked Danny if he had ever seen it
before and that strangle, the minute
I had him in the eye,
I asked him to get out of a rubber guard.
He couldn't get out of rubber guard cause
if a guy's got a good mission control,
it's pretty surprising.
Like you get in a guy like Katie
Bravo's guard and ask, you know,
like try to get out of it. You're
completely clamped down. But the,
the thing about it is that you
don't know where you're in danger.
You don't know which, which Mu, it's,
there's so many non traditional
attacks from that position. But Suman,
Ari figured out this
dope ass grip neck crank.
You just reach under the Chin with the
escript and you really can't fucking
defend it because your right arm
totally trapped in the Omoplata. Right.
You're attacking the shoulder just
sitting up getting an s grip on the neck
anywhere around the neck and just
yanking that motherfucker back.
It's essentially your entire core,
all the weight of your bag and
everything on the unprotected neck.
There's not a lot you can
do to defend hard to finish.
It was very hard to finish it anyway.
A lot in the heavyweight heavyweight.
I feel like it's even worse. Guys are
so big. What is that? What is the one?
Jujitsu and man is one.
If they'd done a stiff at stat on what
the one Jujitsu move in the UFC the most,
the most successful
submission rate.
I'd say Katie because more people know it.
A lot of guys aren't going to pull off,
you know all these kids be interesting.
Is the chat rear naked chokes cause that's
been on a steady choking [inaudible]
up there. I don't know.
It's hard with the gloves.
The gloves is what makes it hard,
man.
It's almost now people have to be
dazed for you to see, you know,
see someone famous or they have to be
giving a cowboy Serone when he had a
Barbosa days. Then even, you
know, just all over. Yeah. Tj.
Hello Tj.
Let's do this shit.
Tough to be a good one. That TV over
there. That's a crazy fight, man.
That's going to be a crazy fight.
Oh,
there's an Minari pulling it off on that
foot. Look at that. On that TV. Pull it.
Pull back it up a little bit,
Jamie,
so we could get a look at it as
the guy rolls repeating Gif this.
See how he gets it. Look at
that in the world. Is that strs?
That is so nasty. Oh no, that's
bad, man. Let me do it to Brian.
No Way Tot death. That's how it went
away. If you've got a neck problem now,
fucking forget that.
That's just from count with terrible.
That's literally how break your fucking
body. Beautiful technique though.
It's super effective. Rarely Plata,
and you just grab his head like that.
Especially if the guy's trying to
release your legs to try to save his arm
because you kind of give up.
Your right arm is trapped now there
he gets underneath that checks,
but you don't have to go
anywhere around the space.
It's basically a net crank and you're,
you're breaking your spine. I mean,
she's a horrible, horrible
position. You're putting so
much pressure on the discs.
It's honorable
man. I mean I'll, I'll show you after
the podcast, the set up, it's super,
super clean and it's one
of those techniques where
it's there the whole time,
but nobody does it.
Sort of like the Japanese necktie necktie
where a lot of guys want to get the
dark. He can't get the Darth,
they don't know that neck ties,
but you weren't there the whole
time. You know that right? You,
you do that Japanese necktie on familiar,
we should go over it after your
Doris is fucking nasty man.
That Darcy you hit mitre on
with that was locked down tight.
That was bank vault tight. Yeah.
Darcy, that's just forever. You know,
things could just come to you for
whatever reason. I see Darcy's everywhere.
It's for whatever reason.
I just see as soon as surgeon and Jujitsu,
they show me the doors and
then I was just right away.
It was just something they showed me
once and it was in my [inaudible].
There's some guys that just like certain
techniques really click with them.
So weird. Now we're like Paul Sas
triangles, Bang, Bang, Bang. He just,
that's his thing.
That guy you'd get caught and Paul
sasses guard you gotta fucking get out of
there and run. That mother fucker would
triangle the shit out of you. It's weird.
Other guys,
that triangle is just dog shit week.
He could find a way to get on
high level guys to the like, uh,
I'll do Darcy's on guys,
super high level guys and then I'm like,
you're not a dark sky. Like No. Like they
don't even, they don't even mess with it.
They don't even care to mess with it.
I don't have to arm bars or whatever.
I don't understand that Darcy is such
a potent weapon such as shit man.
When it with the guys.
The reason I developed it a lot.
It's because with Shane car
I was shooting in on me.
I should come up with something,
right?
So it was gay teens and Darcy's had to
come up with something out of desperation.
Rilla out attack feet.
Watch me in the face.
Browse a beast, man. He's a motherfucker,
dude. He is as good as it gets.
Undefeated winning streak in
MMA. Is that true? That's crazy.
That's the longest I think.
Something crazy. Let's find out.
It's 36 38 well, when you're,
when you're training partners, uh,
Jose Aldo that, no, the thing
is the weight class he's in,
he's fighting black belts and everything.
Everything.
It's hard to even comprehend that long.
The fight streak as a fighter. To me,
that's kind of speed and stuff too. Like
where everybody's fast length. Yeah.
Let's see.
Daniel Cormier,
who was about five foot one picking
dudes up and just look at that.
He's not fight for one five, eight, five,
nine. He's not that much taller than that.
He's five 11 that's a lie. I stood
next to him. I towered over him.
He was like, man, you're tall. I was like,
thanks man cause I love your work that
I was like, thank you. I was like, you're
way more athletic and person. I was like,
I know I wrestled six feet tall.
Go fuck yourself feet tall.
Towering. I was literally, you are
wearing stilts. I was, that's true.
Women's shoes.
Well this is a good meal.
Magni and Tim means you'll get mad at me.
Eye strain within Denver.
We call him the Gazelle because
this kid's cardio is insane.
Insane. That guy has fangs. He's so tough.
He's really tough on animal to both
guys are animals and both guys are very
similar.
Real tall guys for 55 and means he
knocked out Pete Spratt at once.
70 man listen, the the difference between
means and magnesium, magnesium, my boy,
but the difference is means is just
nasty and each switches things up.
Like you'll see Neal,
his movements great,
but it's more of like a
point scoring system for him.
He's just touching like Neil's,
I don't think it's ever
knocked anyone out in his life.
All he's doing is beating you off points.
You'll see a jab of right hand jab right
hand and he's just moving the whole
time. Means does not play that man. He
means reminds me of a Carlos condit.
Isn't that interesting that that's one
of the reasons why magnet can keep going
forever and ever. I was just like that.
He's not putting on a commander. No. Yeah.
That's a weird thing,
isn't it?
Where you're not totally 100%
committing to techniques,
but you can keep going for
a way longer with that.
What do you think about that?
That's what you have to have a,
you have to have a mix of that. You have
to, you look at the guys at the top.
There's a mix, right? You
can't go. For instance,
if we look at the fights recently,
look at Travis Brown and I talked
to her doom last Tuesday about this.
Verdomme said every shot that Travis
was stolen was that had bad intentions,
knockout power.
He's trying to knock them out in one shot.
He was up putting combos together. It
makes for a high as an ad, a high level.
It's, that's not gonna work, man. Guys.
See it and they're getting out of the
way and they're gonna take, you said it,
you said about Travis Brown
and you said there's no method,
there's no method to the madness. And you
said they keys, there's nothing behind.
There is no strategy behind.
Listen, you can't put,
you can't floor your car in seventh
gear and just it's gonna burn out.
You just can't do it.
You have to use all the gears and the
guys at the very highest level are using
all the gears, like looking at dos
Santos, he comes out very relaxed,
Jab, Jab, and then you're gonna see a big
shot and he's back down to second gear,
but he's not chilling at seventh
gear like Shane Carlin. Yeah,
I see what you're saying. I would
just say first gear, first gear,
third gear, but yeah, I know what you're
saying. Yeah. I think that there's a,
there's not good, it's not good. There's
some guys who do fight like that though.
They just explode, explode,
explode, explode, explode.
And then by the time the third round comes
along and a high level guys, I'm like,
cool, let's we're going to drag
his ass to the third round,
the third round we're going to
go to work and submit this wall.
That's why I was really interesting
to really interested to see what would
happen with Tyron Woodley and
Jay and Carlos condit. I agree.
Unfortunately for Cangelosi
and Roy McDonald though, right?
With dollar drag is athlete.
You have to wait before maybe if
he had survived the onslaught.
Woodley is so fucking fast.
Wrong.
You should see this guy
in the gym hit Mitts. Nah,
I don't want to see it scared me
up at night, bro. It's insane.
I don't want to see it. Any might place
third and miss the Olympia right now.
He's just never ever say,
why does he,
why would you wear clothes when you walk
to the grocery store? It's ridiculous.
Just a Bandana just to keep
this cutter from dragging him.
I hope I saw me myths with his trainer
Wildcard Real Pete had some type Valley
Tudo showing
things to do.
I just chill man.
How often is it wildcard?
What's up? He's not an la guy.
How often is he out? He's out here cause
straighten coat. A striking coach Arnold.
Is that a wildcard out here?
Arnold?
I met Arnold doing stunt director now
was an extra in a B movie with heath
herring and heath herring was beating
me up and stealing my girlfriend in the
movie and Arnold was the stunt
coordinator. What's he doing now?
He's playing poker. Poker. I used to have,
he's playing poker. You have more round
shirt. What a fucking legit wild man.
He's hair. I'll never forget
his fight with Tom Erickson.
Tom Erickson was on top of them dominating
him and he was getting tired and they
stood them up and pride and
when they stood them up,
heath herring just goes, Woo.
Fucking slap. Erickson was like, oh fuck.
And he just charged after
herring and smashed him,
kissed him and yeah, hailed him
classic at the fucking stare-down
right now. He shook his head
before he punched him too.
He could tell he thought about
it. He's like, no, fuck this.
He got suspended. That's dope.
Got this bent. They probably
gave him some money to.
These guys are very similar,
but the difference in this fight will
be Tim means it just has a nasty,
nasty streak. Oh, this is one 70 yes.
Means has been fighting. If 55 though,
has he not,
he's been fighting in the MFC,
but before that, when he
fought in the UFC, I look at
this learning, look at this.
Look, what are we doing? He does remind
me of Carl's comment, right? Yeah.
He's fought lightweight, lightweight
quite a few times. I'm going to get to,
that's what kind of tattoo should I get,
guys?
You should get a dove
daddy dick on your chest.
Like Brock Lesnar.
I dealt with a Dick flying loss
twice in the UFC at lightweight.
He lost against Muscovy doll and
he lost against Danny Castillo.
So I think that he was having
a hard time making that weight.
And why would he was only six foot
fucking to these crazy six three bro.
No, it's crazy. It's crazy.
Fuckers that drops off my boys,
Loren Landow and the battery one 17
he's got muscle on him. That's crazy.
What I mean, that's magnes reaches insane.
Yeah. Like I said, the differences,
these guys are very similar, same
size. Magna has great footwork,
but Tim means just has this killer's
Macchiato for Jack Timber. No, Denver.
Yeah.
Means is like a dirty means.
It's like you want to go to the ground
does not cure where it goes, man.
He just wants to finish the fight
magnet will not get tired. Huh? Nope.
Means it's got real
good head movement too.
I like how he that Longreach another
thing that people don't talk about about
Longreach. Yeah, but the long reach,
the ability to bend at the waist
and move away from Shit. That's,
that's one of the things
that Jon Jones does so well.
Best in the moving away from
Shit not getting hit. Yeah.
I guarantee you the game plan
here for Neil Magni is don't wait.
As soon as you hit the cage, get off.
You're going to see them circling,
constantly circling.
It's interesting how different body types
have different advantages like he got
that who some are Paul Horez body.
What ted is just a huge
advantage for ripping off legs.
Rip on a hall of legs and if you
watched his fight with Ivan salivary,
basically anything he does in grappling,
he's just so ridiculous.
Came out of his mom and put her in
ankle lock just to tick is dude.
Do you ever see video of him rolling
with the Mayhem Miller? Yeah.
It just talk to mom about that man said
he was really hung over though. Yeah,
whatever. Whatever. I would say
that too. If I got fucking two cost,
it's trial that day.
Such a monster for a guy like me.
Paul hires is scary man. Me and Doug
Davidoff tried to fight mayhem on time.
We tried to grab him and He Ooh, get
jab. See I like this moving out of Neal.
But like if you see, you see what I mean?
Went by point sparring. It's just Jab,
move, Jab, move, Jab. Well
he's, there's no bad intentions.
It's not loading up on any,
what's the difference between his style
and like the Diaz brothers then cause
they kind of, his brother's
load up eventually but pop,
pop, pop, pop, pop, pop,
pop, pop, pop, boom, boom
to the body. Diaz is, it's,
it's almost like a machine gun.
It's like for five rounds.
They also seem like high level boxers
and comparison. Well, he also has,
Diaz has an incredible chin, especially
nick. They just come forward,
just keep coming and nick as an
eventual cheers guys out. Well,
frank shamrock said it best when
he fought Nick Diaz. He's like,
you can't breathe because he's always
hitting you and every time he hits you
tighten up because even
if it's only a 50% shot,
you still have to hold your breath and
then he rips you to the bottom and then
you're just,
you never,
you never breathe and he's landing 80%
of those 50 shots. It's crazy, man.
He does triathlons and he swam
back from Alcatraz twice. Come on,
stop it. Yes, he did shark infested
waters. He's out of his mind.
I love that guy more than I
asked him to come on the podcast.
I just don't believe he'll show up here.
I would have him on.
I love that fucking guy. Like,
I love my mother, but I would,
I would only have him on if I had a
backup guest. I'm coming please, please,
please, please. Out of the rankings.
Huh?
Yeah.
I don't know about all that.
I don't know what that was all about.
That that bothers me. Just doesn't want
to fight, Huh? No, he wants more money.
He wants more money.
Cause you found out what Gilbert,
because Gilbert's his
buddy and there was a,
a contract negotiation with Gilbert Bella.
Toi was trying to pick up Gilbert when
his contract was over and they gave
Gilbert a shit ton of money.
And Nate is like, what the fuck?
And so there's some sort of contract
negotiation and I think there's also at
that I should pay Nate.
I love Nate and I agree,
but I don't know who his manager is.
I Dunno who negotiated his contract.
I don't know what the deal is.
But a deal's a deal's a deal is a deal.
You got to stick to it and
nice take down by name.
It's one of those things
where you talk publicly,
you talk shit about the UFC and
you're not going to win. Man. What?
What motivation did they have to, you
know, to give you more money? Well,
the other thing is too is guys forget
there's no bigger guy than the UFC.
The UFC is going to keep on the circus,
keeps on going if one of the elephants
fallout. So it just keeps on going.
How about Eddie Alvarez backing out of
the fucking Michael Chan Bell Tours?
First pay view loves. It's gone.
It's gone. It's going to evaporate.
There's not going to be a paper if you
know they're still doing it. They got it.
They found a backup. Right? If some
guy, Phil, who I've never heard of him,
that's the problem.
Oh No.
And now you want people's money.
This really strange bike because it
almost looks like they're sparring and it
doesn't matter. And they'd still,
I told you saw the point sparring.
It's don't look that it's interesting.
Tim means is a slow start.
It doesn't seem concerned about any
low kicks whatsoever. He says, well,
he's just Kinda,
oh,
by the way, this might be one
of my favorite podcasts ever.
Just hanging out,
watching our guys.
Watch him fight just for
guys with their pants. Oh,
tagged them left by Magni out.
Now you should have kept book means
a fucking hanging in there, man.
I brownie you coach. No, I wasn't. No I
wasn't. I said, see, I stopped myself.
I was like,
hold on.
Brian and I have conversations and
they're not nearly as frustrating to me as
they must be to you.
Ryan and I have conversations.
I just sit on the outside
and call the fights,
but Brian and I have
conversations where I go, that's,
that's no last week. Last weekend. Why
don't guys just, just crescent kick,
no crap.
Well you haven't seen my crafts and
kick last weekend during the Mayweather
fight. I have to look over Miu. Hey Bro,
do you mind just shutting the fuck up?
I saw two rounds from me and he goes,
can I shut up bro?
You need my, you need
my knees up one. Nothing
for sure. I want to get a shirt
that says venom. So get a dove. Huh?
How about venom has a tattoo. You do need?
I have a problem.
The only problem that I have with Bella
toward the only problem is that there's
not crossfit's like what do you mean?
Like you know how like if a Bob Arum
promoted fighter wants to fight a golden
boy promoted fighter, they figured
out a way to make it happen for pack.
Y'All made it for Pacquiao,
Mayweather and arguably that might be May.
Whether it doesn't want
to fight pack, pack. Yes.
I want to find new about that. Want to
do the drug test? Oh, I dunno about that.
I don't know. It might be true. I
mean total complete speculation.
That also could be propaganda
from the May where the camp,
I'm not inside enough to speculate.
However,
what were you saying though about
matching? There's smoke, there's fire.
So many people have said that pack,
y'all was doing something.
When a guy moves up one weight
class, you go, well that's normal.
The guys growing when a guy moves up
eight week classes and knocks bitches
[inaudible] that's weird.
Hey,
no speaking as a guy who's
actually done steroids,
I would say maybe he's done some
steroids. I'd say maybe. I'm just saying,
I'm just saying,
I used to take this shit called Mag 10
that used to buy at Gnc at all this shit.
I've done testosterone replacement.
All the Shit I've done.
Mag 10 was the crazy shit ever. Couldn't
believe you could buy it. That's the shit
they would take. Industry and Diane,
I don't know what this mag 10 was,
but they made it illegal quick. But
I did a cycle with it. I grew tits.
My Dick was as hard as hell.
Cat couldn't scratch it.
It was unbelievable.
I never had roid rage with anything that
I've ever done cause I'm pretty calm
guy. But the closest I ever got
to Freud wages is on that stuff.
You take 10 pills a day, you would
buy in a store, take 10 pills a day.
And I was like,
how could I gained 10 day?
I gain 10 pounds of muscle in six
weeks and I'm not know healthy.
Well, here's how I know it's not
healthy. Cause when I stopped taking it,
my Dick just went, hey, I'm
going to see my dick was like,
they kicked the row it, I quit. My Dick
wasn't normal for a month and a half.
Internet searches for bag 10 just went
through the fucking roof. I know, I know.
Not Legal. You can't buy it anymore.
Okay, let me see if I can find it.
If anybody finds mag seven,
it just makes you shit.
You'll find that in the store.
And that's the thing that I'll say
that I did steroids because I did this.
I mean even though it's not like it's
not considered a steroid because he could
buy it at GMC, GMC rather.
It's fucking steroids, man.
Biotest mag 10 it doesn't exist anymore.
You can't buy anymore more.
it's illegal now. Yeah, it was incredible.
I can't,
might've been the greatest thing
I've ever life. It's 10 lbs.
Daily recommended dose. I did well the
daily recommended, just whatever it did.
Turn your fucking monkey.
It was crazy. But uh,
that was when the game plan is
for either one of these guys.
I was recovering from an ACL,
so I was taking it at
the same time was taking,
I was really lifting really heavy because
I couldn't go everybody. Yeah. Yeah.
All upper body,
lower body.
For the first couple months all I
was doing was bodyweight squats.
Just very light, trying to increase
my, um, my flexibility and all that.
Tim means all over him. Man. I
like his nickname too. Dirty bird.
Dirty bird. Dirty bird just
said sponsors. Nah, I'm good.
You know what I like about magnet?
Put my dirty brick logo on the
bag in the back of his legs.
You know what I like about Beltour
Jimmy Smith, that motherfucker,
great guy and fucking on
point as a commentator,
he's very clear, very clear, knows
his shit. Black belt in Jujitsu.
Damn means hitting him with a head, knees
to the head when he was on the ground.
I don't want to graph what the fuck man.
He definitely got one hand
was down one or two for sure.
It's a tricky thing, man. I don't
like that knee to the ground thing,
knee on the ground. You can
kind of sit there, right?
You can job the system by touching your
hand and lifting it up and touching your
hand and lifting it up. That doesn't
make sense for fighting to me. No.
I think the knees to the,
to the head for grounded opponent should
be legal and less a part of your body
is touching the cage.
Why did they make that illegal?
Because it's dangerous or this is
where I think it should be illegal.
When a guy's got his head pressed
up against the cage ain't going.
You can't go anywhere.
You can't move.
That's why I like soccer kicks and
stomps and pride because you could always
spin your head around and go under the
cage to avoid the technique. You know?
You know why?
I don't think they ever make that illegal
because a America is not ready for it.
Teeth. They think this hotel
flying to violent as it is now.
Then the terrorists
win the terrorist wing.
You can't punch somebodies head like
a soccer ball, but why not? I mean,
I know Bob. It would
hurt. It would hurt to it.
You would get some of that fancy
wine. Unwanted press. Yeah,
but I don't believe in unwanted press.
I think it's bullshit.
As long as you could debate it. Why?
Why should you be allowed to wheel?
Kick your guy in the head.
But I can soccer kick probably cause a
wheel kicks harder to get off. Mirko Cro,
cop soccer, soccer kick.
Ron Waterman the face. Yes.
Horrific.
Little short about Ron Waterman chucked
me out with this titties when I was a
white belt. Literally put my face between
his tits and choke me up. Come on,
I'm conscious unconscious or you tapped
that but, but he almost broke my nose.
He almost broke my,
he's a big fuck.
And he was doing it for Jesus and
real set of tits on him though.
And he was choking you for Jesus,
right? He shows me for Jesus.
Did he give you a cross afterwards or
maybe a Bible? Give me a little pep talk.
Slap on the ass. Give me a pep talk
after he bought me a sandwich. Pity.
I'm super embarrassed. How many
shines goes. Don't worry brother.
He did that to me before.
Look at that sandwich to the KFC thing
that they're promoted that double down.
I'm a big fan of that.
Hell No.
I'm going to fast food home with
12 you don't need to have it.
You know there's a place
in Montreal called Joe Beef
and they did a variation on
a double down, ready for this
two chunks of fog. Voila.
So time is of deep fried duck liver.
Yeah,
in between Bacon and cheese.
And it might be the best thing I've
ever had in my life. You know what?
I wonder if I don't like
shitting my pants so I don't eat.
I do not eat that stuff, bro. You want
to shit your pants? Okay. I don't,
but [inaudible] good question.
If anyone,
if you want to shit your pants,
drink a shitload of
coconut oil. Okay, sure.
Oh, I drink that shit every day. Not a
heavy dose. Heavy dose in the morning,
I have to run back and I
said to the gym or cocky
rocket shit out of my
asshole like Kale shakes.
I drink a Kale shake in the morning.
Those that love me for me,
it doesn't bother me, but it just, it's,
it's basically like
rude or down the drain.
They say you're not supposed to.
You're not supposed to
drink too many Kale shakes.
Too many spinach shakes and
things because it actually,
because it's a big leafy green vegetables.
There's a lot of toxins in the lead
is not toxic. Wildcats, healthy Brian,
you could use listen,
knucklehead. Listen, I ahead.
You've got to stop saying shit like that
when you don't research it because you
can't. No, you haven't because you can
counteract all that stuff with calcium.
Oxalic acid is the problem, but you can
counteract it with calcium. No, no, no.
Here's what, here's what I'll say
about when you and your friends,
when you eat,
when you eat a lot of meeting,
a lot of raw leafy greens.
Here's, here's the,
the issue with the problem is that a lot
of times leafy Greens because they have
to keep insects and they
produce oxalic acid.
He countered that with calcium. Just
go online, not just stocks, Chasse,
fuck these other things.
Well,
what are these other things where
they're all Tim means it's all over Neil
magnate. That's, that's no close
fight. This is fucking great fight.
Whatever things Brian come
toxins that keep, no, no, no, no,
no, no other talks. You
know better than you.
Green Leaf expert pro and googling
shit before. Talk about it.
Okay.
I have a very [inaudible]
back guys. Go to their back. That's twice.
We've seen that with Karrie Yasso dos
Santos and cane Sean Shelby people not
even watching the fights guys fucking
ring side of the greatest fucking
supporting of it. Look at
Bruce Buffer. He's sleeping,
sleeping. Sean Shelby people.
Too many fights. You're never
going to see that for me, man.
Never going to see that from me.
You, you see me ringside in a fight.
You see me either glued to a
monitor or watch the fights.
People always ask me that like,
you're bored. Fucking never. Never.
When when those bells ring,
especially a fight like this,
this is a great fucking fight back
and forth. For sure. Fuck yeah, man.
It's a great fight.
Brian Coogler,
people telling me that David Asprey,
Dave Asprey, and John Duran, Dave Aspery,
you fuck you not even paying attention.
Dave Asprey offers solutions.
He offered solutions. Calcium was one
of them. God Damn. Fuck I fucking,
you hurt my feelings because I love
you. Whatever, dude, I love you but you.
You give out shit tweets
they fucking hate. They hate it
comes at me. I'm like, I love him.
I ain't got you don't know him. He
tell you fuck whores. We're flawed.
I am flawed too.
Everyone's flawed.
You know I have a real problem with
people that only complained about people.
You don't talk shit about themselves.
It really bothers me.
Know there's a lot of that
with people who write blogs.
I never talk shit about
anybody I said bore.
You're just talking shit about vegetables.
I'm a preacher about spinach.
I spent I juice every morning of fuck
every morning. Yeah, I feel great.
You look very toxic feelings to Brent.
It looks pretty healthy.
By the way,
a healthy fucking animal is going to
be a sabbath. Looks pretty healthy.
That'd be healthy. He's a fucking
UFC fighter. Got No choice. Really.
It's a professional comedian voice. I
don't have any convictions. Oh fuck.
I don't fight for my kid. This
man can be the difference. And,
and look at me and starting to slow down.
Neil Mag,
these main training partner named
Mark Cart. So is that right? Oh boy.
Oh
Wow. So close means fucking mouth loaded
out of it. These gates in his long legs,
man. Good body triangle. Oh good.
Uh, but rather a bag. So when,
when needed that switches to
mount, when Neal came off, uh,
I think it was the ultimate fighter.
14 when chin, Carmen was the coach.
He lived with Nate, Mark
Cart and his wife. They loved
having them around so much.
He basically stayed there for a year and
became their babysitter. Is that right?
True Story. Wow. Take some freaky
stuff was going on. I like to think,
well, your information before you say
things like that, that's on Google.
Brian Magni.
And he keeps trying to get that back
triangle but can't get it. Look at me.
Man's controlling that alarm. Yup.
That's a big move. But get this,
he gives up the fucking mountain,
goes to butterfly half guard.
Neil was trying to isolate that
arm in arm. Yeah. Get that arm.
But it doesn't have the arm
in the right position. No.
If you're going to isolate it,
you've got to go down and cross.
It shows you can go to mountain.
Why is this doing?
Why is he going to head and arm
the first place? So weird position.
He's holding Super Weird
homeboy get past the side.
He's just taking a break, taking
a little break there. You know,
he's still in his half guard. He's
just taking a little break. Was there,
but Neal's given him all sorts of space,
like oh space. When I was over the baby,
I was over Hixon Gracie's house once
and we watched coliseum 2000 is a mixed
martial arts event in Japan back in the
does a, when a Hixon fought who? Nakia.
And uh, that was think Hickson's last
fight. And uh, was he talking to him?
Look at him. I dunno, but Neil, one to
one I think. Where were you saying though,
Joe? But Hixon uh, was, uh,
it's so amazing watching fights with Hixon
when he starts breaking out positions.
He, yeah, he, he gets this
gusted when he sees space,
when they see these guys,
they're shitty
side controlled shitty mounts and he goes,
when I go to,
when we start, we're neutral
position. Well if I go to one,
we're not going back to wall zero.
We've started at zero.
I moved to Juan and from one I go to,
I'm not going back to zero.
I'm going to one and then two,
two and then checkmate.
Yeah, he's made and then
they say this, I believe you.
But by the way, maybe it has. No,
I've never seen I does he ever
cracked jokes in his life?
Is he dead serious all the
time? I don't know. I mean,
I'm sure if you're around
them and you know you,
you've fucking been strangled by him
sufficiently that he knows pretty cool.
You understand your position.
The mean he is Frank Grillo and my buddy
trained with him for a long time was on
his competition teams.
Z,
a green baret navy seal zipper that you
know that name ever guys serve combat
riot police, little former
world champion. He Won.
He won the world
championships and everything.
Tell me about her friends cause they
make you a better person, but he said,
he said
that all your friends does to make you
a better person and you find that a frat
girl, it doesn't even exist.
He was in captain America.
I played this one of the Jerky
boys. No, he's an American play.
One of the Philippines.
I don't mean I didn't see it but then the
latest captain America had a big part.
Okay. And he said that picks someone,
let you put him in and his purple belt,
anybody put them in and literally like
a choke hold and count the 10 he'd be
like,
I'm going to get out of this and ten nine
hey tell you what he was going to do.
Black belts do that. Yeah, he would. He
tell you what he was going to do to you.
I'm going to put you in an arm bar,
no matter what you do to it.
He full back control with the hooks in
a rear naked choke locked in and you
would get out. It's ridiculous. It is
Neil getting the win, but it's not.
If you let a white belt do
it to you. Yeah, I would let
a white paper that to me,
I agree and hates Kale.
Yeah. Yo magnate. Nice big.
That style, that style of, you know,
never committing 100% to everything.
What's his name ran off.
Huh? He's not to me Brian.
He just lost a really big fight.
A big fucking event.
Where's on magnet train now he's at
grudge. Oh Colorado. You know what?
You know he's not, he's not
at crutch. Head coaches.
Lease for bowling and he's with a
date mark cart and Cody Donovan,
those guys in Denver at
elevate. Ah, yes sir.
Team elevate and they turn out that muscle
farm. Jim, that Jim's read Dick. Is it?
Ah, state of the art. It's from
Kennedy was on the podcast here.
They talking mad shit about muscle
farm products. I've never had them.
I've never had it myself. I just know
the facility. I love six star products.
I just know, I just know the
muscle farm. Jim Is Nice.
Their products probably make
you shit your pants. I Dunno.
I Dunno.
I'm not a big fan of shitting my pants
bad. Depends what I'm spoiled with that.
It depends on what I'm doing.
I'm Sarah and I ain't got
nothing to put on a good movie.
Shit my pants by the way. Thanks
for animating that. That shit story.
A video that Joe and I did you see
animated it. Oh Dude, you didn't get it.
Some Guy Online. Yeah, they animated.
It made it really funny too.
There's so many funny fucking people.
So great.
Was your shit story about you running
around from away from the girl in the
woods when we were talking about when
we were doing well, I was telling you,
oh the one the shit story when we were
we shit shit on a stick to your story
that no one's animated.
Someone hear my call.
The story that you told about
running away from girl? Yeah.
Brian was hiking with a girl
and he had a shit, his pants,
so we made a game out of it. I ran into
the woods. She's like, what are you going,
we are back. I'm trying to scare you. Oh,
shouting out of my ass hole
shouting out of mass mass.
It was literally by the end it was like
as I, and she came walking in, I was like,
Ooh, look at the hawk. Ooh,
make faces at her [inaudible]
here and has a beer,
more tasks.
You finally heard it cause I couldn't
get around and tie and she goes,
are you sick? I go, I
think so. She smelled it.
I had to walk her through it
back through the minefield.
We had to turn back around my floor,
asshole,
all chasing dirty.
You know if a girl can deal with
that, if you can say, hey listen,
I don't want to lie to you,
but I got fucking crazy diarrhea.
It was like a first day and guess what?
She couldn't deal with it.
In fact it's are a year later. She ran
out of the fucking door, but that's good.
That's good.
You got off light.
What would you do if you on a date
with a chick and she said she has bad
diarrhea. I said, it's, look, we're
human. It's all good. I would,
that's what I would say. Well,
yes. Are you tad fucker anyway?
Well you definitely fucker anyway,
but even I probably wouldn't fuck her
right then and let her wash up. Diarrhea,
diarrhea doesn't really get my dick hard.
That's the thing is I wouldn't judge her
but some people would get upset at you
and that's like just a weakness thing.
They would sense weakness in you but they
probably sense weakness in you because
you tried to hide it. Whereas the
guy like me would say, hey listen,
I got fucking diarrhea so we deal
with this or not. It's all good.
I can understand if you hate me now,
but I'm going to go shit
behind this trip I was in,
I was in an acting class and
this huck, the guy goes, hey,
I got to say this before
because this is on,
I fucking hate this nas
commercial and I'm done.
You can't keep showing
this God damn thing.
What was the guy throws all these wild
kicks and the other guy comes out and
punches him in the face and
then drink some caffeine. Yeah.
Punched him in the face and then eat.
And then these are folk who cool,
calm and collected caffeine
because I was knocked out.
I totally need to be stimulated
because I just knocked the guy out. No,
because I wa
I was once on a like really super early
in dating this girl and I got food
poisoning,
were sleeping in the same hotel
room together when we met him.
We met in Greece. So I drink a
bunch of Ouzo and pass the fuck out.
I like terrible food
poisoning. Quick work. Yeah.
Cause I thought maybe it
helped the food poisoning.
He could call up like a fucking
baby. Woke up, woke up here.
Oh my God. And I was like, wow,
what? I was like, no, no, no, no.
And she just jumps out at
[inaudible] and a huge,
that's a huge issue
you have to throw away.
That's not what's important.
What's important is what happened.
Tours with the girl.
It was a lot of laughter.
And anytime I tried to be like
romantic and we'd be having a wine,
she just looked at me and just
crack the fuck off. I'm like,
how is he says I shit myself. Right? And
you're like, oh, your friends are the
best for you. Look at this fucking
pregame. This girl's tits are popping out.
She's with a black guy or on TV.
I'm upset that your voice gets very high.
I get angry that she's hot as fuck.
That's ridiculous. Have you had,
have you ever had a girl blow up your
bathroom? Oh yeah. Oh, I deal breaker.
I have lose my number. No,
you blow up my bathroom ever.
You and I are different now.
I had a problem. I was fight
of the night right here.
Oh yeah. Cooking, uh,
Derek Cruickshank and Eric Cooks
Superstore about to fight right now.
New Breed and Detroit superstar
about to throw down great
coke, Duke Group, Phis trained fighter.
And so his Cruickshank, by the way,
when I was at Duke's camp, um, I was,
I was trained at Duke's place when I
was in Minneapolis and Cruickshank was
there and coke is one of his boys.
So this is kind of interesting.
I didn't know that. Brendan, you have a
tough, this isn't crazy. I gotta just say,
please don't say something stupid.
[inaudible] job. You got a bottle opener.
I'm nervous as shit when,
when you see that little thing pop up at
the bottom says you have to see one 74.
I was like this.
What makes you scared?
I'm scared. It's just nervous. I can
see it. So you have to think about it.
Do you try to avoid thinking about fights
is much as possible before you do them?
Um, that's a good question.
By the time I get home,
I'm still exhausted. I really
don't think about it. I'll wake up.
Sometimes I'll sleep like shit thing
about our Lawsky, stuff like that. But
I'm just so exhausted
by the time I get home.
I'm really just know I would never compare
myself to anything that you've done.
But I did some competing when I was
younger and one of the things that I found
was I won the US Open
when I was 19 years old.
And one of the reasons I think that I
want it is cause I didn't think I was
fighting and it was because I had fought
the week before and I had injured my
hamstring on my groin rather.
And uh,
the, the tournament was the
week after that and I was like,
well I'm not going to find him. I'm,
I'm hurt this thing I need to heal up.
And then I woke up the morning of the
fights and I had a bunch of donuts
and then I had some coffee cause
I used to have a paper route.
It's always to make money. When I was
fighting, I said, get up in the morning,
I'd get up at 5:00 AM and I would
deliver papers from five to seven.
Then they go back to
sleep. Wow. And so, uh, I,
I had these fucking Dunkin donuts donuts
with powdered sugar and lemon filling
and a,
and I had some Boston cream donuts and
I was cooking for you lit up with sugar.
And I was like, I'm fucking
fighting. So I got in my car,
I went home, packed my bag and I w I,
I not only did I not think about it,
I told myself I wasn't fighting.
Right.
So for a week I was relaxed as fuck
and I did no training whatsoever.
I mean, I might have
liked, did some stretching.
I would definitely worked out in the pool
because that's what I would do when I
wasn't fighting. If I was
injured, I tore my, uh,
Sartorius muscle besides my ACL is one
of the biggest injuries I ever had was a
bit, it's a hell of a sartorial,
connects your hip to your quadricep.
It's a pretty big muscle. And it was
a pretty bad in terms like a dinosaur.
It was a for a few months,
I couldn't throw any kicks.
It all, it was pretty bad.
But, um, so besides that, this I'd
hurt myself. So I said, you know what,
let me just take some time off.
I did a little swimming and this and
that and the day of I decided, fuck it,
I'm fighting.
But I fought so good because I had slept.
I slept good. I relaxed I the
whole week, I wasn't nervous.
I was Z.
I had zero nerves the whole week because
I was convinced that I wasn't fighting.
So it was just a sugar rush,
a split decision. And it
was one of them. I did work,
but as a taekwondo fighter,
it was one of my biggest victories.
Winning the US Open.
It was like a big phone.
I've also heard from some athletes
when you're a little bit injured too,
it kind of takes some of the pressure
off of you for your own performance.
You're like, well, I'm injured anyway.
You just relax. You don't have a train.
Like I think Bernard
Hopkins will you telling me,
Bernard Hopkins says that
it said something like,
why would I train most of these guys?
Overtrain he doesn't even train them.
Well now as he's older and Larry Holmes
said the same thing, he realized,
why am I training an hour and a
half for a 30 minute fight? True.
And that just comes with
experience and about Roger Federer.
The top tennis players do not
practice more than two hours a day.
It sounds really surprised. Hours
a day is a long, it's a long time.
We were just talking about
some bad motherfucking sport.
Nobody's playing in Chins off your
head. Play four or five hours, bro.
I don't give a fuck if
you need to learn tennis.
Rob Talking about [inaudible]
for two hours. Here's the,
here's the best today.
Take it guy who weighs about the same
that I do and who runs an ultra marathon.
He runs a hundred miles,
right?
Give him a month off and I'll fucking
strangle him. He doesn't have a chance,
is no
chance. You know why? Because it's not
a marathon. If you lock up with me,
you don't know what you're doing. I'm
going to choke the shit out of you. See,
a marathon is nonsense. You just
running. No one's kicking you.
No one's throwing rocks at you.
There's no niggers historic,
difficult ignorance in this room.
Ladies and gentlemen,
I will make you
give me some volume to drown out.
You see my fucking wheel kick?
I'm going to flip out right now.
[inaudible] whoa.
He's the underdog.
Huge underdog.
Plus the 55 is what does that mean? What
does, how do they come to that number?
Put $100 on him, right?
You know what I'm saying?
He's basically a three to
100 almost four and a half.
That is fucking interesting.
That's an interesting fucking who dog.
Who makes those yards.
They what experts are doing that?
Who is doing someone sets an
initial line cause a bedding. Whoa.
He's minus four 50 sees a heavier fabric.
Look at that Tattoo.
Of course he's mine is four 50
what is that? It's terrifying.
I think it's a Jrr Tolkien or something.
Who knows?
It's probably his favorite
author. Hello, Gary Cohn.
Gary Copeland is as wide as he as tall
and he's not very tall. He's fantastic.
He is fantastic about Chrissy. How
she's good girl. By the way, Brian,
if you ever want to put
you said she's a good girl.
You played tennis gentlemen in the room
and make you make you quit or table
tennis is an athlete. I felt this
back. He's got to valley for a back.
I appreciate it. Let's see.
Cruickshank and oh gosh,
a tag coke with right hand double
valley tuto shorts, cooked, shine.
Coming off of that victory is very,
very hyped dude.
The way he mixes things up is insane. You
just can't train for it, but the kicks,
the angles. His hands are low, dude.
He's trying to make him
pay with every kick.
That's what you gotta do with the kicker,
man. If you're a coke going to Barbara,
a chart who gets the
girl? Well, the shop does
his fight versus he's too small.
The giant is my first as Mike Rock.
When you see a girl like shop, you just
got to get her away and he's on fire.
I've got to run. It's true
cancer. It's fucking, it's Ariel.
I disappear when I'm standing next to him.
I disappeared.
I looked like a cup of coffee.
I could be a candle.
It doesn't matter when you might just
go girls, Brian is aids. I'm like,
I look like I do. He wouldn't get
tests. I'm all gone by the way.
Definitely the last guy on earth that
gets tested. Definitely not like Bro.
It's not meant to feel fine. Whatever.
I just say he fights, I play tennis,
whatever else.
He has his Duke in and out with the A's.
He's happy to just be a battle.
Just a huge cock block.
His body is a battleground
with a big kick to the body.
You know it's interesting. Like I said,
because when I was at Rufus Sport,
Cruickshank was trained
there when they had the UFC
in Milwaukee. That fucking southpaw
stance, it's always tricky.
South paws are tricky man.
They are tricky, but they're
opened up for right hand.
Right,
but they also start to deal with,
they're used to it more
than you are correct.
Unless you train on a regular basis.
They're really good. South paw,
south falls are tough, man.
Metro was a south pole.
It's tough to find a high
level South Pole guy. Oh, nice.
Little snappy, snappy, right.
Jab is a motherfucker man.
Straight rights or how
you beat a South Pole.
But Cruickshank I was so impressed
with him in that Mike Rio Fight.
And I know Mike Rio is primarily a
grappler. So, uh, the difference between,
Ooh, nice inside leg kick. I like
how he set it up with the punches.
He's got the boat, got crazy
explosion this fast. Good Job Ryan.
Cause I liked it.
I like to come that myself,
I keep myself going because obviously
I'm surrounded by enemies in his fucking
surrounded by people would not
appreciate tennis except for Aubrey.
Aubrey gentlemen. Oh God,
thank God you're here.
God,
you're here fighting a bunch of parents.
Oh right hand by Cruickshank. God Damn.
Tell you what, whoever made these odds,
men are way off. They need to educate
themselves. I get confused sometimes.
It's some of the odds. I mean, Adri
has made a killing allegedly by,
I was a betting man by, uh, some of
the things that I sometimes, you know,
he'll come to fights and I'll go,
whatever you do better
fucking hell.
He's
out Bro. I don't know. Yes, I do
know. He's just taking punishment.
Oh, he's hanging in there. Gary is
close to stopping this fight. That's it.
Oh shoot.
Oh
shoot. Victory. And I would
told, watch this setup.
Those odds are off.
I text my brother right before we got in
and he said, he said he should. I bet on,
I said, Detroit superstar.
That's a big victory.
Who the fuck made him a three and a half
to one underdog and a four and a half
to one favorite for coke. Some fuck. Who's
used to doing an NFL and NBA was like,
Oh yeah, I'll do GFC this week. Some guy
who doesn't train. That's all that is.
That's a guy who doesn't train.
Look at this head kick. Watch this.
Oh,
and by the way,
Brian caught him with the
foot towards Sam writing.
Did you and I know the difference.
You and I know that Gary stopped the fight
because he got tired of being so low.
How about the others who's squatting?
He gassed out and he's like,
I gotta stop this fight.
[inaudible] that's that stick legged man.
I would have stopped that fight. I gotta
be honest with you. You wouldn't have no,
no. It wasn't enough. I mean he was
definitely in trouble. But look,
when Crookshanks on top of him,
he's dropping these shots and every
time she goes shopping these shots,
he's grabbing him. Coke is trying to get
up. I mean, he's definitely tagging them,
but I don't think I would have stopped
that fight because I like to see a guy
survived that kind of shit and come back.
And I know that sometimes when guys burn
themselves out trying to finish a fight,
it can like they could gas
and just got ourselves here.
Stole your can do a back flip on
a trampoline on the trampoline.
I can't even do it on a tramp fucking,
I can't either. I can have a problem.
We could have.
I took the time.
I did gymnastics forever cause I used
to hang out with GSP all the time.
He did gymnasts. Those I want to be
like him. So I started doing gymnastics,
then he went back to Montreal bottling
it. Worst body for gymnasts. Not really.
You got really good.
Sorry. I got really good.
And then as he's trying to criticize you,
he's so tall.
Shut down your body for fucking you.
You wouldn't get
sensitive about your body.
That body for gymnastics,
by the way.
I'm six five, two 50 I'm not
really. Yeah, you do. Well,
but the one objective kept doing it and
then I was getting really tired from it
and he's like hurting my knees.
I was like, what the fuck am I?
What am I doing gymnastics right now?
If you tell your needs covered and
there's 10 year olds everywhere doing way
cooler shit than me, 13 pounds.
And I was like, you know what?
I should probably be in the gym rolling.
I'm at the fuck out of there.
I've never been back. Good
for you. That's very smart.
[inaudible] no one ever want to
fight by doing backflips. No,
it's the only reason I went so I
could do a backflip. I'd be Brian,
do you think this, this fight is a
fucking interesting fight, right?
It's a couple of interesting
fights in this card.
The me a Dan Henderson
is very interesting,
but the thing about me and Henderson
is like, Henderson is off the TRT now.
Trts been banned. They shut that shit.
There's a couple of guys who were like,
Ah Shit.
He Tour Vito.
I put out a statement and
I feel I'm a beast without
TRT. The Holy Spirit. Really?
Yeah. He said the Holy Spirit tweeted
that out. I'm a beast without TRT crutch.
All Ladies and gentlemen, you
just got a new superstar. UFC,
the Detroit superstar. That's
a big, huge women. Huge wing.
Eric Coco said, fight for the title.
Remember that he was supposed to.
Although for the title,
that's a big God.
I hate seen guys lose.
Well I do,
but I like seeing guys win at the same
time and one of them has to happen for
the other to happen and I'm a big
fan of Cruickshank get to really,
I'm a really big fan. All right, let's
come back. This guy takes a lot of heat.
Jon.
Anik,
he takes a lot of fucking shit online
cause he's on because he's a fucking
commentator.
Take Shit was you don't I take Lenny
just doesn't bother me with Joe has what?
Six G Gilly and followers on Twitter
you can take some hits. You take kids.
It's just, Oh look at that
head kick Crookshanks on him.
But see this is my point and I'm
not saying it wasn't bad stoppage.
I'm just saying if I was standing
over him, I'm fighting through
it.
A let him fight a little bit more because
I don't think that any of these shots
are putting them away. He's
not flat lining. I agree.
His head is off the mat and he's
trying to make him the route away.
He's trying to figure out a way
to get out of that scenario.
But when the guys on top of you and a
guys blown is wildlife that swarming as a
guy who's experienced a lot of fights,
I think that you got to let a god try
to fight out of the bottom position
listener. Yay. Yes,
because the guy's head, he never
laid back. There's his dad.
I mean it was dad's karate instructor.
What did he have kids?
It might be wheat belly dance.
It might be we found that
the inventor across food.
No, he ate better of cross. That's insane.
Do you think did he pulls down
outside and go dad, come on.
We're going to go walk in
today is walking dead. Oh,
earlier must be a good
teammate versus bedroom wall.
I did not see this fight, so it must be
an exciting, can I spoil it for everyone?
No,
please don't tell Dan.
I was working out of a gym at
the House by the way, gentlemen.
And unless you have a cage while I
was uh, yeah, I keep lines in it.
I like to keep mine. I like to
work out why? Watching fights.
It makes me scared.
What was that Mafia guy who would bring
you down to the basement to see the lion
if you want to vote with you?
I think it was, um, fuck.
Do you know you can you follow the stone?
There was a mafia guy who had it kept up.
They kept Elian downstairs and uh,
and the informant was talking to you
as well. If they, we had a problem,
we take them down and see the lion,
that's all it was.
All we needed for the guy to comply and
they just had this huge male lion down.
I would imagine that's the last
way you'd want to die. Well,
the Uday and Qusay whatever who
say, yeah, some, a lot about scenes.
Kids used to feed sweet
up dogs to rottweilers.
They was not feed the dogs for days.
And then they would
throw people to the dogs,
including like women that they raped. They
would rape women on their wedding day.
They would find them on their wedding day,
steal them away from their,
their groom,
raped them,
and then feed them to dog William Wallace
when that shit was at biggest assholes
on the planet. The biggest assets
complete. Total. There's a hell.
I hope they're just fucking
emails,
shit heads for the rest of time.
I hope the little kids step on them.
They come back as snail. Just keep coming
back to stay. I was going to step down.
We get run over by cars. Splott they live,
but they're in agony for like 20 hours.
Just snails.
[inaudible] snails come back
as another snail. Crows,
snails on the salt flat. STOMP, stomp.
Impressive beard by this man. Only
impressive because he bothered to grow.
At this point in time.
I'm a little tired of those beards.
I gotta be honest with you. It's getting
a little old, right? Everyone's doing it.
Yeah. That's what it says. The
guy who can just sign that.
You need a little bit of attention.
I can grow one. I would agree.
I think it's a sidebar. My Beer. Do you
know and look at how fucking don't know.
If you have a big Dick, you don't have
a rich dark as to my beard. I do have.
You have a big Dick. You
need. Don't need a big beard,
but if you have a big Dick and
a big beard, it's like, Whoa,
I didn't see that common.
You look like a monster with a tail.
You have a big Dick and a big beard.
Multifaceted mother fucker.
Do you write your own poetry?
What's your Twitter account like?
A lot of retweets.
If you got a huge beard,
do you trim your pubic Bush or did you
just let it go? Wild pans on the couch.
Hey,
usually if you're going to bid like that,
you kind of don't give a shit
and you have that seventies Bush.
I take it all down guys. Just say
it now. I got a number three razor.
I take it down and keep it tight. A
chick who didn't like it if like, oh,
big left Sam. Oh, that's that
same guy stops the fight.
Very good stuff. Oh boy. He's thinking
about flipping, but he's like,
I think my legs are gun tower on
his back. Turned upside down. No,
I think it's a condition. It's
a, what could dcs? It's uh,
originally the DNA helix from
Sumir. Really? What is it?
I'm just shitty tattoo. I think
it was, I don't know. What is it?
What is it on its back? Come on,
Luke. Could deal in this corner.
Former one 55 guys. Guys during the break
just say, you know, if you like comedy,
I'll be comic strip on
the back there again.
Where you just train left. Boom. Straight
left. Yeah. When are you going there?
I'll be there this Wednesday.
Thursday, Friday, Saturday.
But how long will you just there?
You were there recently? No,
I haven't been there for over
a year. I know. I'm confused.
I can't wait for Vancouver. Oh, we're
going to have a good time. Ah Dude.
I'm going to Vancouver on June 13th
and a we're in Lloydminster one 74 yes.
And Callum will be there.
I will be there. Wait,
I will shine and I'm shooting
my one hour special soon.
I'm shooting my special in Colorado.
Confirm what I love about [inaudible]
22nd and 23rd at the comedy works in
Denver. Joe Rogan would probably
open for me for what I want.
Our special asked me. Let me know. I'll do
it. Alright, I'm done. I'll be happy to.
I love you. I'd be happy to
introduce you. I want you to do that.
Let me know if I get the week off. I'm
fucking in there. I know my brother,
my favorite and my favorite thing is
listening to you laugh in the audience
while I'm doing my standup.
Well we work together in DC at the Improv
so fucking hear you cackling the whole
it was the fun.
That's like when your friend is that
you end up just doing stand up for your
friend. I think that's a artimus
prime or whatever the fuck it is.
One of the Bandanna which are
those things called transformers.
Transformers back. You know Marky Mark's
and then you transformer movie. Yeah.
I can't wait.
Who
told him to be in that moment?
It's like someone,
someone offering you John Oliver.
I know I need a manager.
You want to be in the transformer
unless you want to fuck Megan Fox.
I would say no cheating. You want to
be in a trailer right next to her? No,
and our trailers butted up next to
each other and less mine is open.
Take the hinges off mine
transfuser doors together.
I want to know if she's showering.
Do you need a towel? A towel?
She's not even in those
movies. Right? They got,
they know she had a
problem with a director.
She is in though the new teenage
mutant Ninja turtle movie. Yeah.
I was actually on exactly
what I want as a kid.
I love teenage mutant Ninja Turtles.
Let's make them realistic.
Said no one we met. Was she in that
movie? Fuck. Was she in the movie?
Is that the same guy who directed it was
the guy has a problem with the gay guys?
No, it's not. That's the other guy.
Michael Bay did t nine sings turtles.
The Brian Singer's the ones
having a problem with gay
guys coming out and saying
that he fucked him.
I got a message for all your little twinks
that fuck Bryan singer and now you're
running. You Yap. Listen,
you knew the fucking deal.
When you get into a pool and there's 500
other twinks in there and you're all on
ecstasy, shut the fuck up. Exactly.
Okay. The guy who hooked you up,
he brought you to the party.
He didn't have to bridge straight
guy who fucked here. Take it easy.
There's not a shortage of decent
ass straight. Oh, sorry. Sorry.
There's a shortage of twinks.
Okay.
Settle the a great tweak is a
great gain out of that. Using it.
Would I be a twink in that gate? Well,
I'm too old. No, you're definitely not.
What's a twink? You're a guy buys
twinks. Yes. You might be in,
you might be, there's like different
words. You know there's a good bear,
but there's like otters
and there's a whole ladder.
It's like a horse bear forest of animals.
What am I, why do all I know is big?
Because you are a barrel road, but
you're not here. No, not here enough. Oh.
Tweakers the tweakers like a
little, a twin. A pink, like
a soft as smooth, like a,
like a feminine boy.
I might be an honor.
I got my daughter likes bears though.
I think when I'm working with,
I'm going to
take your shirt off with smite.
We might be a muscle otter then.
I'm technically a muscle water.
It's a definition when the ATO
look at that muscle water. No,
Brian's a chicken head in the gay
community. Are you kidding me?
Look at the fucking, what does it, is
that a four pack almost can see your abs
was right oil though.
Dude
died for beat 50 40 look good.
Grow
with the numbers man. You and Donald
Sterling just doing the damn thing.
I'll tell you,
there's a lot of people that saw Donald
Sterling with that chick and they
ignored the racism and what there's hope.
So by the way,
81 year old guy can fuck that. 20
something year old. Check there.
So if I, if I get, what's his name?
He's got a banana and played pro.
Forget about all that.
Look at Adam Sandler and doing another
movie with Drew Barrymore and expecting
someone to watch that. You know what
you know who watches those involved?
Those bullshit movies Guy
Madison content stuff.
Yeah.
So I watched that content stuff.
When you prepare for a fight in June
in general, cause my job so intense.
Like last night I went saw that movie.
Uh, neighbors. I would see that movie too.
I love Sephora. I love all was so funny
man. Do you see this as the end? Oh yeah.
Funny movie. Funny family. Craig, Anthony.
Funny fucking movie man. So funny.
So neighbors was good neighbors.
How many stars? Craig Robinson
was great and that fucking movie,
he's funny as shit was towel is a towel.
That every seat sweat.
Yeah, true. Oh my God.
Seth Rogan and neighbors.
I give that movie on the entertainment
of four out of five. You know what?
Winning awards. You don't
go there to learn something.
Just go to be entertained.
I love how James Franco Dodge
that 18 year old bullet.
I love the way you said
Franco, Franco, Franco,
James Franco. He was uh, he was trying
to bank some 17 year old. Was He?
He was great. He didn't bangers that
was pretty like shooting the shit
out on him, right?
Yeah. That fucking cunt.
She should be boycotted for
life by the way. But him, um,
what he did was pretty
creepy. What happened? He was,
he was a on Instagram with some chick.
She was 17 he was like,
when you turn 18 like come
meet me, you know, and uh,
and she like printed all,
took all the tweets that he sent her
or whatever it was and a chats. Yeah.
There's something creepy about that and
mean we know chick 17 and you're fucking
James Franco that the deal is you're
supposed to back off and go stone.
Are you supposed to say,
okay,
it's not like I'm in the desert and
you're going to have to fuck my kids and,
and eat my neighbors Rolodex
of 50 pot bitches who over,
you got to try something different.
The problem is there's some
dudes that are innocent.
They have a real thing with teenage angst.
There has to be a better way to,
and [inaudible] has been through
two divorces with a sex swing.
Scott's on her breath. Yeah. Like an
older chick with cigarettes in her purse.
It's disappointment chick who's gets a
text from a guy who goes to fuck you and
then throws the phone in the
toilet and kind of bad skin.
I don't like, like all that. Will you
like a girl who is in love with you?
Whatever. Joe. I don't
want to talk to them.
You don't like a girl who sees Brendan
Schaub and it's like I can get that guy
you like a girl who knows she can't get
Brennan Shab Cause Brennan Shabazz bow
busy with something superior.
I like a little broken.
I like a broken
way. Always have. And you used
to always be like, why are
you with that? I was like,
oh, like it shut up little broken. I'd be
like, come on, whatever. I look her like,
what are you doing? I Dunno,
I don't, I'm drawn to it, man.
I like a little refused to want
them to fall in love with you too,
which is always odd to me. But that I
just like making a connection. Yeah,
but you want a guy, it was really
hard to tell what was going on.
We both know what's happening here.
Right, right. And they're like, yeah,
no you weren't that guy. You we have
a connection. Yeah, yeah. Yes, yes.
I fall in love in the moment.
There's no question the same way as I
don't know if you fall in love. Well,
I don't know if you fall in love,
I think you want them to fall in love
so that you can feel good about it.
When you guys, when you asked
her, you knew she was the
one when he met her. Well,
she get pregnant. There's some
game. Listen, here's the reality.
There is no perfect
person, not me, not you,
not anyone. And it's when you
enter into a relationship,
it's really all a matter of
where are you in your life?
Where, what? What are you deciding?
What decisions do you make as far
as like how you proceed and when,
and I've had friends that
are like, you know, hey man,
I'm thinking about getting
married. I'm like, stop.
Stop what you're doing right now and
understand what you're doing because a
marriage, all it is is a
legal contract with the state.
That means you're going to have
kids and you want to have kids.
Marriage is all good,
but I didn't get married until I had kids.
And on that smooth,
I'm going to take it.
I'm going to have a pickle
break right now. Go much.
Why am I going if I want to connect
to grab, grab hold on. Pickle.
Yes. It's that close man. And
just so everybody understands,
there's nothing wrong
with getting married.
There's nothing wrong with having
kids. Nothing wrong, all those things.
But it tends to be the right time
and know the right person to,
it's gotta be the right fucking,
it's gotta be the right scenarios.
Pickles, pickles, pickles up.
So when we play in tennis,
Brian, I'd love to hear that for
real. Are you around tomorrow?
We're gonna do it tomorrow. Tomorrow.
How about Monday? Possibly. All right.
Yeah. Do you play a lot? But
I love it. Yup. Yeah. I'm
obsessed with tennis. Right up.
I boxing and tennis now.
I don't know.
Pretty different. Hey Bro, could
you please get tougher bro?
I you do something. Did you eat
beef jerky or something like this?
And I am tough. I mean, not really,
but if like if one of the
toughest comedians and not bad,
I'll go for the top thousand. Here's what
I, you're not tough. But if he, if he,
if my friends in a fight,
I'm going to, I'm not,
I'm not going to stand around and I'm,
I'm, I'm gonna, I'm gonna help you out.
These are mustard pickles.
I've never had these pickles.
Grillo's pickles company
sends me these pickles.
They're fresh pickles from Boston
and they're fucking amazing.
But I'm pretty excited about,
I'm going to pick on a grid so
that you can get in on that.
Everybody could get it on that. I've
got that on. He goes through, everybody
is going to sound like,
Oh, here we'll sat.
So my buddy is fucking blew up ma'am.
Beers too.
I bought some Sam Adams.
Oh,
uh,
the perfect storm to
shit your pants again.
Pickled mustard pickles and a shitload
of battle gallon. Bulletproof coffee.
I've had, I've never
had this before. Yeah,
it is good.
It's unusual garlic here or by what?
People aren't complaining on Twitter
because I'm eating your own microphone.
Go Fuck your mother.
I have to say,
you go fuck your mother.
Ah.
And you're like, Ooh, can porn cause
so because I heard your children,
fuck you
podcasts.
All kinds of people.
Just went out to go get pickles
right from this here in the crunch.
Grillo's pickles
and a lot of you like, what's
so good about pickles? Pickles,
who there's the James Franco
thing. Huh? Let me see.
Did they have a picture of this girl?
He's got a movie coming out. This,
uh, the trailer came out the same day.
That story broke. That's not a hoax
hoax that I'm rolling for teenage girls.
His movie is,
he plays a coach that gets involved with
one of his players who's at 17 year old
world PR move
average. Guess what? None of us knew that.
Now we think he's just a psycho. Yeah.
I don't know about that, but I'm
looking at this Godzilla commercial.
My Dick hard as a rock. Right.
Very excited about what,
you know, what not excited about it, man.
That's cause United doing tense shit.
See me,
I'm not worried about fighting Andrea
Orlowski because I don't have to.
So, um, I'm watching Godzilla and
I'm getting fucking pumped. Yup.
The other guy till it was
some bullshit with machinery.
I've got Joel commercial or
Ronda Rousey right after it.
Uh, for me. I'll take it
Zilla I wouldn't say Rhonda because
Godzilla was definitely going to kick your
ass and you know it going in so fuck it.
Oh well try again.
And the next incarnation, Rhonda, you
feel like you might have a chance.
That's what fucks.
I don't think I have a chance
and I'm under no illusion.
She choked me out on Instagram.
Guys. Follow me on Instagram.
[inaudible] funny thing
that you do on Instagram.
You do have a really interesting
thing that you're doing what you do.
The splash on the devil. That's
fucking hilarious. Really funny man.
It's really original to ma'am. Good.
I'm going to do, I've got more to come.
Well I fucking hope so at least.
Ah,
Brian's doing this thing where he has a
cell phone on one side and the iPad on
the other c has two things talking
to him at the same time. That is me.
I always have a you doing that
when you're on the road? Yes.
And isn't one like hey fuck guys. Like
wait, what? Yeah, the guy. I was like,
fuck yeah. Keeps me. Yeah.
You have to watch it. Well,
this is a broad who was in the broad,
this is
the girl who's in love with Wayne Newton.
Here comes here comes who still
knew and we knew their guys excited.
Whether that, wait, how does
he not know? Buzzes girlfriend?
He doesn't know for the same
reason why bodybuilders don't know.
They look ridiculous or
anorexics don't know. The liquid
gets a fucking, did they run out
of people to sponsor the UFC?
Did they not have a guy in the office?
Does quality control?
It goes enough with the fucking
spinning. Na's guy, bro. Real quick.
Let's talk about bodybuilding.
I think there'd be a game sport.
It's guys suck for competitions.
I actually went, I had a
friend who's competing.
This girl competing in one of those. I
went to the first time ever guys on guys,
right guys? It was the craziest,
scariest thing I've ever seen in my life.
Wait a minute. Racks on racks, on racks.
Guys. Philip, who's Polish muscularity,
he's Rasta. Philip, do
you know it's interesting.
Casa Philip who left ray long goes camp,
you know,
because he's 185 pounds, most likely
Weidman's one 85 they might have to fight.
I don't know what all the drama was.
Do you, do you know anything? Um,
but since then he's is not
looked as good as last.
His last two against Luke
Rockhold and Francis Karma. I uh,
on my last fight with [inaudible] UFC
one 65, me and him shared a locker room.
I'm not making this up.
This guy did maybe half a jumping jack
and went out and fought no warmup.
Zero. Look at, I'm not a sweat out sweat.
He does not warm up. He didn't hit Mitts,
he didn't do anything. He did kind of this
half ass jumping. Jack goes, let's roll.
And here I am sweating my ass
off in the back, getting ready.
Look at this fight because
he's fighting Lorens Larkin.
And my take on this is that Larkin is
like a really multifaceted striker.
It goes a lot of kit, very
tricky, very tricky. But Phillip,
who is almost exclusively a boxer,
he's like a sprawl boxer type care.
And he's been getting
taken down a lot lately.
That's how he's been losing his fights.
What Carmona really kind of tricked him.
I don't think he ever saw that coming.
I think he's on the call it up though,
because Karma is GSP.
GSP is running double the differences.
Phillip,
who has crazy knockout pyre?
Larkin's really not known.
Does he though does fill up
whoever you crazy knockout mouse.
Who is he knocked out? Who's the
last guy who knocked out though? Uh,
just see his fight with Jared Haman.
Oh Man. Talk about brain damage.
Really not fun to watch.
These are my new favorite pickles.
I can't get enough of these pickles. I
don't feel good. I'm a little lightheaded,
but I'm eating the shit out. These big
goals. It might be the bulletproof coffee.
There's no,
she's pickles with the fucking,
it's the perfect storm to shit your pants.
30 seconds people.
I blocked five guys who complained
about me chewing pickles. By the way,
are we allowed to ask?
I know you guys don't make predictions,
but if you had to put your money on
the silver Brown fight, can I get,
can I get a call? Which fine.
On the seventh round main event.
The main want to wait for the main
event? Yeah. No, I like Matt Brown.
I don't like the fact that Eric Silver
is a big, uh, a big, he's two to one.
Who makes these odds. Crazy eyes. Fuck.
Do we do it? Math four fights in a row.
All knockouts.
Eric Silva's one one seven
fights in a row as it is. It? No,
it's four for whatever it is. Um,
I'm always impressed with him.
You might, you might be right on seven.
Maybe it's four knockouts in a row.
I'm not unimpressed with Eric Silver.
I think Eric's Silva's a fucking,
I think Matt Brown spot tougher guys.
But don young good knocked
him out and that makes me, uh,
not that don young calves out and animal.
He is here at one, two, three, four,
five, six, seven, six in a row. Fulfill,
fulfill the 44 knockouts
in a row, right? Yeah.
His last loss was so proud of
him and a good team. Either way.
Oh, you just got tagged Phillip.
Who's tired of losing man?
He was ranked, what? Six at one
point he was up there. He's a beast.
He's so strong. His leg would imagine
he is strong. His legs are insane.
Look at his calves. They ain't giving
those muscles way in a cracker jack box.
You know what I'm saying, folks? You know
what I'm saying? Not that'd be me as a,
as a, as a the kids creek,
he's got to go tease balls.
Good leg kicked by Larkin in there and
Larkin used to fight two oh five right?
Yeah. Do you don't lock in
as a win over Robbie Lawler?
Do you know that and striking? You look
good. Oh good. In that Robbie Lawler, man,
he's really clean as far as
like as tech and you know what?
In Strikeforce he was a, he was
a killer. I think the UFC was,
I don't see a big jump, but
it's different. Strikeforce
and UFC or different. He's,
he's stumbled a little bit in the UFC
so far are conceives a very can be,
just hasn't gotten current combos.
The haircuts freaking me out kid and play
kind of thing going on in the eighties
back stop. What about vittores? Vittores
haircut. I'm a fan. I am too. I like,
I like them in cornrows and I let
them in and we were see towards
white face and make it what
beautiful woman. Yeah, yeah,
yeah. He's, he's a named mark
cart to train with him. His
wife came and I was like,
he's a fucking,
you don't spit it back if I can stare
at it or I will eat a spinning back kick
to the face and, and uh, ooze classic.
He's getting hot chick dual Larkin and
the truck hit Costa Philip who are thrown.
He's got beautiful kids, right? They look
like x men. All of them. Yup. Beautiful.
Both of these guys have their
back up against the wall.
Oh, big kicked by. Largan.
See that's a different gene.
Larkin is the kicking techniques.
I mean Philip who threw a kick but missed,
but Larkin is real clean boots.
Going to counter when these kicks
with a big right hand who maybe,
it's funny how it's used a
little more active than this.
These Kickstarter started like they
start changing like what becomes a trend
now? Everybody is throwing those oblique
kick copied copycat league. Tony Man.
Yeah that front kick Anderson does now
everyone does it. Everyone does it.
We'll kicks everyone wheel kicks.
That's a cool thing.
Superman Punch was the thing like a
denim jacket. Oh about two months ago.
I'm wondering waiting for body shots. Look
body punches to be like God, that's it.
No you're fighting a high level
striker that he's gone to the body.
If he's comfortable gone
the body by Philip boot.
Oh it's coming back right counter
one of those kicks. Hey who am I?
We got ourselves a fight here.
I want to say that you took it
out of her own. We tagged them.
Taking the wind out of my
sails wasn't gentleman.
These guys are sweating where his cost
of Phillies guys strong cause you still
training on Long Island? Yeah, he's
still on the east coast. I know that.
And his managers.
Lex Mcmahon.
One of the best in the business
that Catherine plants her. Um,
is there anybody that would ever fight
with an implant? You imagined dudes.
That's the number one. Number one
implant for guys, his calves. I'm weird.
You think they'd have a Dick Implant
by now? They do. How do you know?
I don't want to talk about it in Africa.
They so rocks in there sometimes. Yeah.
Say what you fucking with me
and the entire continent. Oh,
lucky. Went Down Phil Pool.
Huge win for holy Shit.
Yeah. Some tribes. I don't know why. I
have another picked on that Dude Phillip,
who he's got, he is jacked. He
is sweat and Brian, he's jacked.
Wow. That was a big women. Here's, here's
my felt. This got some muscle lost.
His last two man, he needed that one
had to do or die and not, not only that,
I think you might've been
the first guy to ever stop.
Lorens Larkin is tracked for us or the
UFC. Look at him. He's fucking wobbled,
ma'am. A lot of power, right? Remember I
said a lot of power. You're talking shit.
Boom, boom. Oh, clean, bright, happy.
She's got short. That right hand is
he hit his head up. Folks at home,
when you watch how short
he threw that punch,
let's call it the tower
that's called power is power.
It's technique because he didn't wind up
and pull it way back before he launched
it. And that's why it
landed in the first place.
And so people got understand
donk. Oh, beautiful box.
And that was a beautiful right hand.
There's,
you're knocked out hard left hook.
And here's a right hand cod donk.
Dot.
Dunkel oh, look at that. Lumped
it curd underneath his ear.
What is that? That's not even a
bone. So you know how Joe Silva,
you'll see him in the ring
when he congratulates guys,
what did he say to you?
Well, if he's unhappy with their fight, he
doesn't come in the ring. Even if, right.
If he's happy comes in and says like,
great job.
Has He ever seen on the
weird to you something like,
you're my idol. I was like,
come on. That's true. Really
never. How you doing Bryan County?
Just a liar. He's your cock is big
as I hope my Lavar Johnson fight.
When I just kept taking them down, beat
were booing me. I was like, Yo, where's
Joe Head? I won my fight when the bank,
you just walked right pass and I was like,
yeah,
but that's what you gotta do when
you're fighting Lavard Johnson.
That guy's ridiculous. What I want on the
scale and I'm like, I turned my coaches,
I think he's on steroids and was like,
Nah, you're the same size. I was like,
I look like him. Like yeah.
I'm like, Oh fuck. Yeah.
I was in the hotel, the
hotel taking selfies. I
asked him to chicks and then after
the fight my coach can, good Lord,
that guy was way bigger and
way. Fuck man. He's like,
we just want to say that so you weren't
so scared and he tested positive for
steroids.
Steroids is fucking hilarious.
You wear a panty behind live t
by 15 seconds behind live TV,
which was asked for that. I got in
the clinch with him. I was like,
this is not snowflake. This is not stuff
like, oh, the Internet is behind by,
he was just ridiculous.
A strong, so folks,
if you're watching this and you're like,
you're behind,
it's because of the Internet.
So back you fucking Tivo up by 15 seconds.
And by the way, if you don't have
Tivo, go fuck your mother. All right.
Fuck your mother. Fucking people have
to walk. I was at a friend's house.
They don't even have a DVR.
I'm like, why not use candles?
Why not live in the guy told me, how much
do we a message by pigeon. Alright, yeah,
send it over to stand with a good
friend and a, you know, their family.
My family friends and I saw that they had,
uh,
they had the channel where glory was on
the head spike. I was like, oh perfect.
I'll just watch it on the DVR. I'm
like, Whoa, what is this? Where's your,
where's your fucking Dvr? I'll try
to pause their TV. I can't pause it.
What the fuck is happening?
What am I living in a different time?
Do you guys have steam powered machines?
Philip was interviewing himself.
That's not true. They don't look
anything alike, but the joke they do
chose may do. What does his shirt,
there were tea with a backwards torque.
Dawn do it. What? Whoever made that shirt
stop was going to say it doesn't stop.
Kind of confusing. If you want to get
your name out there just like that.
With this going to confuse the fuck
out of people. I'm confused right now.
Costa Philip, who's a good
guy, man, I'm, I'm happy for
him. He too went into, listen,
I've lost two in a row.
That third fight is so stressful.
It's not even funny because guess what?
You lose you going back
to fricking dancing,
shaking your ass for guys white and a man.
You're back at Starbucks.
My balls so sweat. You lose.
If you had a high level and you lose two
in a row and you're getting paid decent,
that third one, you better win.
Otherwise you're getting your pink slip.
He was under a lot of pressure.
Is that like a hard rule or
is that just kind of informal?
Depends on the guy. It depends
what you're getting paid. Yeah.
That's a weird thing.
If you have like a good contract,
like there's certain guys that come in
and they're like highly touted and they
lose a couple of fights in a row, 400
g's and you lose two in a row. UFC,
he's like, Huh, what are we
doing? But if they're fun fights,
if it's an exciting fighting,
you're fighting top level guys. Oh,
look at that fucking right hand.
That's beautiful. Tell you why.
Losing two fights that third fight,
most stressful fight of my career.
I've been in the UFC a long time.
Quite a while. Beautiful combination.
That left hook right hand
that's short right hand.
Why I told you he's a fucking
knock our arms, Bro. That's right.
I said what happened to flight in the
kid podcasts available centered on Fox.
Oh,
they must have listened to me
telling them you're going to leave
the fucking offering you guys to come
over to hire primate.com for free.
We've got Travis Barker right on
Wednesday. Oh, that's cool. Yeah.
Yeah, he is. He knows a lot about
finding. Yeah. Seems like a good dude too.
You know what, man, if he's one of the
nicest people I've ever met, he's so nice.
You know when you meet someone,
the show nights,
you think they want something from you?
Like, what do you want me to see my Dick?
Or something like, what do you,
what do you want to ride in my call?
Whether that's your first option.
You must want to see my Dick. Well,
why is he so friendly? Nice. Yeah. Cool
man. Just start taking my clothes off.
I don't know what's going on, right?
I guess this is what you want.
Oh, I'm not used to it.
When he was on pump two,
he was on punked with
Ahmed Ahmed. Ahmed. Ahmed.
Ahmed was talking crazy shit to him in
a restaurant and he was like, come on.
What the fuck it, let's go
outside. He likes, he's a rockstar.
He's ready to drag someone
outside of fight with them, Bro.
That dude's cardio is insane. Really.
Jim, he does like 12 rounds in a row.
Just submits,
moving insane
drums to do the best drummer in the world.
Drums are a lot of cardio,
man. Hey, hey, hey bro.
Calm down about the best
drummer in the world, but,
but I understand who's the best
drama for sure. For sure. Calm down.
Don't know, cause I'm not a drummer
expert, but I imagine fucking Neil Perch.
Got Something to say. Who's Neil?
Perts drama for rush. Holy Shit.
It's fucking pot. Yeah. 85 and has a
grape nuts. Hang down on the drums.
Hey Bro, guys, Neil Peart is
probably the, I tell you what,
Google best drummers.
I just did best drummer in the world.
Okay, Neil Peart according
to you. Fuck you Jay,
Bro.
Fuck guest.
You don't get to say
James, James, James, James.
There's a lot of people that
believe in different things.
The sparker is definitely one
of the best of all time. Uh,
you're out of your
fucking mind. Okay. Brian,
what's your p's and q's to understand
that you're out of your mind and I've had
to take you serious and Neil
Peart from rush is on this.
What I just looked up, John Bonham
from led Zeppelin is number two.
I am writing Chad Smith, red
hot chili peppers. Number three.
Why?
You know when they say still alive,
it's like is I'll lead the greatest
boxers still alive because I'm pretty sure
that Vladimir Klitschko would fuck him
up right now. Ryan would fuck them.
Point well put. Well put. Yeah.
I mean there's a current drummers
Travis brown still look at and we'll get
[inaudible] fucking drum set. I think
of that. Any more questions Brendan?
Shop but doesn't know anything
about drumming. Travis Barker.
I take drum lessons. Brian, you're 57
you don't know when they have to is.
You have no idea. I've never
heard of that. That band,
Travis Barker can drive upside down.
I'm pretty sure Travis
parks a bad motherfucker.
I will slap you right and I talked
back. Collins is in here. Joey Jordan.
A lot of people think who is he from?
Do we have from young?
From a slipknot Korn.
Okay.
Rob Zombie is another one that folks
consider to be number one. Yeah,
whatever. I believe the guy from the
Allman brothers, Gregg Allman, who is it?
Who played the drums,
I believe notes might be the best in oats,
which,
oh, by the way, I'll tell you who's
a better looking guy than there.
Then a big brown Brendan shop and
that would be Mr. Silva Silva fear.
He's got his throwing fucking
waiver throwing for a hair.
I am looking forward to this fight.
The only thing that I can hope is that
this fight goes five fucking rounds.
Got Beautiful Hair. Really? I
wanna see I wanna I don't wanna.
I don't want it to be a quick one.
One because they can't get enough pick.
If I was a betting man, I would
have bet on the over on this fight.
I'm just saying I just can't hold.
The three arrows were one and a half.
I can't believe that all of is the for
one and a half minus one 50 people.
If you're out doing,
if it goes over to go over one and a half.
Yeah,
that's how much you get for that.
It was minus one 50 so you have to
give away a little bit, but it's still,
I think there's a pretty good chance.
I would tell you to bet the
fucking farm on that man. Brendan,
did you train with the Michael
Bisbing? Yes. Recently. On a Tuesday.
How's his eye? Good. Okay.
Your Voice was too active to hire folks
at home and not going to get into.
That was a weird pause cause he went good.
It seemed good. He team, we were sparring.
He's going hard with a heavy weight.
I tell you what, it was our warmup
round. He came at me like a banshee.
Are we show video here, chairman? By
the way, here's the trivia questions.
What is a banshee? But don't look
it up yet. What's it been a banshee?
Uh, let's a band shit like,
gosh, it's an avenging spirit.
Not Bad. What's it Bangy.
It's a, a very upset spirit.
Fucking liar.
Some shit that screams that doesn't fancy.
It's such shit. The little kids
believe is real. A banshee,
I believe and I think
is a, an Irish, Irish,
very of mischief.
Please look it up.
Why are you trying to like gain Brownie
pans from the oxalic acid debacle?
Sorry, go the stupidest facts
of all time. Oxalic acid.
Once you go make me some fucking
juice. Hey Bro. Yeah, Brian,
that's when they'll come back. I
went, Hey Brian. I had no comment.
What about the toxins?
The other toxins,
the toxins in fucking leafy
Greens will kill you. Feel Great.
I'll tell you what they are. They're
oxy there. I'm fucking chlorine.
Nick [inaudible] color farts.
What's wrong with you? Really?
What is wrong? I am a lawyer.
I say things for attention. We don't
like looking things up cause it's a bore.
Who are you? I just work on instinct.
You fuck. It's hard to blue.
When did Brian just drop all this stuff?
You stopped doing combat sports.
You stopped juicing. You played tennis
juice in my life, but I will. I'll start.
Oh, juicing. I thought you meant
choosing this truce. I drink a,
I have a press juices delivered to my
house every day. That's gangster. God,
it's so good. You were right. Very good.
Banshee's a fairy woman who begins
to whale. If someone is about to die,
don't be fucking my boy. Aubrey.
Just don't fuck with no Joe.
He doesn't say shit unless he knows what
he's talking about. Is very different.
No wonder you in that respect.
No wonder if Aubrey doesn't know he's
got this crazy thing he does. He goes,
I don't know.
You should try it.
Brian makes the block that I love
that. I don't know. That's a boring,
just trying to ask me any questions. You
can answer it. Don't be scared. Try to,
I now if somebody has somebody
has their hood open in that car,
I'll come over and give him by
giving him nothing about car.
I literally will come over and go find
a ranch on the side of the road and pick
it up and see if it fits. You.
Check the fucking a carburetor.
You have distributor caps,
disturb your calves cause she fucking,
how's the HVAC valve on that?
This is a big fucking fight from Matt
Brown and for Eric Silva. Look at this.
Here's the rankings. See, okay.
Matt Brown, rank number seven.
Eric Silva, not even on the
fucking top 10 for Internet.
They have him as a two to one favorite.
That's crazy.
Look at how tough. Look at
that shit. Crazy feels holding.
That's also why allegedly Aubrey has
made a shit fuck ton of money. Yes.
There you go. On my advice,
allegedly, what is the percentage?
Allegedly like 80% allegedly it'd
be, hold on, hold on. Hold on.
One fight where allegedly we won 10 out
of 11 so you allegedly talked to Joe
Rogan before you put money allegedly
Callahana for only certain ones.
I go bet they'll fucking farm
on Tyron Woodley allegedly.
Hey Bro, this certain ones, those
tips. Yeah, I will, but you won't bet.
You'll go to a buddy who
was used to be a navy seal.
He gave me contrary advice. I wanted to
make him happy, so I showed him my slips.
I held him. I have a friend,
hey, let's hear this. This
breakdown. Oh, it's me.
How convenient.
This is a fucking great fight,
man. Really good fight. Well,
I'd love just Matt Brown for a little bit.
Hurt his back. Yeah, that's what's I'm,
I'm interested in this. He
nodded. Not just hurt his back.
You fucking herniated discs.
We had to pull out of a big fight.
You're supposed to fight condit cold out
and herniated discs are not something
that heals up real quick, man.
You know, I know. I, I, I had, um,
you know,
it took me a long fucking time of a lot
of different types of therapies to deal
with. Uh, my, uh, bulging disc that I had.
You know what's weird is, is Matt Brown,
he came to Denver to train with
us one time and I was like, oh,
this pacing would be insane watching
him spar Neil Magni nope. Nope.
It's a different,
like his octagon pace.
And is sparring paces
completely different? Well,
it probably should just putting in work,
you know,
he's probably smart about that and that
sense. Was He, um, was he with Beecher?
Yes. Yeah. Beach is a good
dude, man. A really good dude.
Features have got to turn me onto
my tattoo artist. Oh, really?
Who's your tattoo artist? Aaron
Dellavedova from grew tattoo in San Diego.
Great fucking guy. Do you have to
go down to San Diego? San Diego. He,
um, he did a, I talked to Beecher. I was
like, who did your fucking sleeve? Yeah.
He's like, Karen DeSalvo over the guy's
fucking awesome. He gave me his number.
I called the guy guys cool as shit.
I saw stuff online and it was worth it
for me. Do you have both? Just your arms.
Both guys are Erindale widow and has your
back and chest onto, oh, nothing's done.
But these just arms. Both sleeves. Both
done by the same guy. He's awesome.
I want to get, I want to get just one
sleeve. I don't know. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I did too. But I had this uh, idea to
do this. Me and Moto Musashi sleeve. Oh.
It was kind of important to me, so I
said fuck it. That's book of five rings.
I love that. But yeah. Oh,
we'll get Eric Silva slapping
himself before Matt Brown does
their pro there. Press poster for this
fight. It was pretty fucking epic.
Pretty towns. Yeah. They're pretty
intense dudes, man. Yeah man.
It's like the young lion versus
the established line. Cool.
How old is this kid
killer? He's young. I mean,
I don't think he's holding than
25 I think he is. Is He? Hold on.
I want to say he's 27 or 28 okay,
let's pull it up. Eric Silva.
I feel like he didn't feel like he
made Bieber was separated at birth.
One went to Brazil, right? He's,
he's actually 29 29 yeah. Wow.
I guess I'm pro basing it on how
old he was. He looks 20 words.
You look 21 looks 21 yeah.
I kind of forget that guy's age.
The answer the UFC at
Leesville Eg. Oh, look at him.
Ishmael. His last name is Ishmael.
Ishmael lead. Gee, that guy,
he rides one of those little crotch
rockets and he takes him to Aziz. Oh yeah,
he does. He's a serious to some
end goals out here. Yep. Yeah.
He's to work out and goes all the time
though. He's still doctor. Great Guy.
I saw him the other day. Guy, original
Carlson, Gracie black belts. He is choked.
Hoists Gracie unconscious
in Rio on the beach.
That was a community fucking heads out,
didn't he? Didn't he beat Hendo as well?
Jujitsu match. You might be right. Yup.
It might be bright. Believe he did.
He's a serious guy. He's a tank that was
back when, uh, there was the rivalry,
you know, the Carlson Gracie
rivalry with Elios kids.
The Leo side and this hall is rivalries.
It's crazy.
It's a family.
Even the family like holy [inaudible]
criticizes Henner and he ran for doing the
grace university. Like I don't get
that criticism man. I really don't.
A lot of guys think that you can't
have Jujitsu instructions online.
Of course you can. Is it as good as
being there in person? No, it's not.
Is it still good? Yes, it is still bakes
Jujitsu available to a lot of people.
Can't get to the, I have a
buddy lives in Kentucky, man.
He lives in the middle of fucking
nowhere and him and his buddies,
they watch videos and they practice
together and that's all he has.
He's like two hours away.
You can simply get better that way.
But that's how rich Franklin learned.
Hey,
you got a lot of guys learned like that
man Tanner Bas Rutten's said he was,
he'd been beginning of
kind of self taught. Well,
he definitely learned a lot of
grappling that way. Not Striking.
He's also just a gorilla is pos.
How about,
how about when he was doing like just
demonstrating shit for us? My God,
let's just like he's getting Regena keen
done at the same place where I get mine
done on his arm, on his neck.
He's got a real problem though.
Here's for folks at home, man. Here's
the thing that my doctor told me.
Once you start getting um, numbness
and then you start getting atrophy,
if you don't catch that shit quick,
you have a small window where your
nerves have the possibility that he just
stumbled there and slipped.
That scares me.
He ripped his fucking knee right
there and then played it off. Um, you,
you have a small window when you,
uh,
when you lose muscle and size
and you start atrophying,
it's only a couple of months he said,
and in those couple of months,
if you don't get surgery or they don't
get something that reduces the pressure
on the nerves,
those nerves can die off and then you
never get them back to you and there's
nothing you can do. So it
never comes back 100%. Never.
Cause Bas Rutten was telling me,
you know,
he was trying all these different
things to get his nerves back,
but it's a long fucking time.
It's been years.
He's got this massive
atrophy on his right arm.
Like boss had neck problems all the way
back that to the tea Yoshiko Osaka fight.
When he won the UFC heavyweight title
couldn't wrestle training for that fight.
Same Shit is Carwyn had like serious neck
injuries and couldn't fucking wrestle.
And so then I think it was sons of
anarchy was doing stunts for the,
he fell on his head.
It's spiked on his neck and he's
like [inaudible] fucking pain.
Herniated disc in the neck,
atrophy of the nerves like the whole deal.
But boss is just such an animal.
He's like one of those guys
that like if he gets injured,
he just sucks it up and keeps working out.
He's the one,
the original filers who was a freak
athlete just picked up things so fast.
He was one of the best
strikers in the early days,
asking strictly how would boss
do nat who have the old guys.
I know you can't ask that because we're
so involved. The whole hall comes out.
The day that it's evolved.
I tried to do the Bas Rutten
jumping double kick on the
trampoline all the time.
It's totally useless
unless you're in a movie.
Hence the trampoline and two
dummies are running at you.
I would imagine Matt Brown
said to a super high pace,
being in some townies would
come out pretty amped up. Well,
it's also a big question like how,
how much time is he had to fix that back?
You got to remember this is five rounds,
so that patient,
there's no way you can do it
for five rounds. Just can't,
I don't know. You know,
I don't know what his injury was like,
but I know that like Matt Serra,
when he came back from herniating,
a disk in his back and he fought GSP,
he was really not the same. It was
really not the same. And most guys,
when they injure a disc in their back,
you're back is a lot like your knee,
which is a lot like your brain.
You know when,
that's a good analogy like a guy doesn't
understand what a brain injury is like
when you get owed and then you
get CalEd again easily afterwards.
It's just like tweaking a knee and you
rip it the ligament and then you get it
fixed but then you need is
always kind of sore, you know.
Well when you hurt your back though
that's so different cause it's connecting
your nerves back injury?
I don't think so because I've never
seen Nate except I guess a brain trauma.
I mean but I've never seen anything as
far as like a mixed martial arts related
injury that can just end it.
Backer that yeah,
back or neck and end it and your,
your arms shrivel your leg show.
I have a friend and he had
two back surgeries and for
whatever reason it didn't
take and his leg is,
he has one leg that's shriveled.
His,
his right calf is like a bone to heal
and he's super self conscious about it.
He like wear sweat pants, he won't wear
shorts and he's all fucked up about it.
He's hoping it comes back,
but the reality is if it's more
than a certain amount of time,
it ain't coming back.
It's tough.
And so if you're out there and
you got any sort of an injury,
fucking don't tough it out. Deal
with it, deal with it immediately.
Go get it. Prolo to fuck. Yap.
Prolotherapy prolozone had
probably therapy on my neck
and I worked for me. Yeah,
no he didn't. Yes, you had
a neck problem, man. Yeah.
Join digits here and I had a
showering. No, I had told I really did.
I pull it in therapy and they
shot him. They shoot. Um,
I think a saline solution in
your next Chicago, whatever
it is. And it worked. Ooh,
that sounds intense. Oh
boy. This is a nose to nose.
Exactly the same height about to
kiss good. Soft there he goes matter.
It doesn't matter.
No.
You know what's interesting about Matt
Brown and like he doesn't move that
fluidly.
Like if you looked at the way he moves
his strikes and everything like that,
you wouldn't like there's certain guys,
you look at them like perfect example,
Hector Lombard. You look at a move and you
go, Oh, fucking Christ. See this place.
Leave this space now.
That just super kick.
He was kissing guys. Fuck down.
Spacious. Maybe with his back,
he might just let them take
them. Boom. Oh boy. Oh boy.
Pulls him over on top. This is what I'm
telling him of time at the high pace.
Charged up home crowd,
body kit.
Brown breaks. Motherfuckers
too. Does Ooh, good body kick.
But he's sold like Eaton shots and comes
back. He's not a front runner, man.
Big liver kick. Oh No fucking
hurt, man. Don't stop it.
He's not. He's not locked out. Oh He's,
he's gonna Survive. He'll survive.
But look at this. [inaudible] Silva's got
his back. He's got to work that defense.
But you know if you can
get ahold of a glove,
this is a good little break right here.
If you get two on one, you're pretty safe.
Oh, this is just a neck crank here.
How about zero on one hand? No.
Why does it need turn into the choke
turned turned towards his right.
He doesn't have body triangle either.
He might be taking a little break you as
long as it take to recover from a kick,
like that tight body kick.
You're in trouble for a while.
It depends entirely on how bad and where.
God George me and dropped him with a
fucking body shot and he hit him with a
vicious body.
Punched 200 201 I was trying
to get to the right of it.
This is great. Back control sort
of, but he's got his legs crossed.
If Matt Brown steps over that and he
could make it at least let him make his
legs uncomfortable.
He doesn't have his legs crossed again.
But then like when Hixon choked out
food knocky he has legs cross too,
but Hickson, I am worried about that
shit. Come on. Oh he's got a deep now.
Shit. Nope. Oh boy. It's just a neck
crank. Ope. If it fits under the shoulder.
What's he doing? Oh man, that is a neck
fucking Kremlin. It's not under the neck.
Okay.
It's under the Chin there you go to
o two on one for the love of God.
Defend your,
it's such a weird thing is to find your
body triangle, but he's not rolling
dot. Not Rolling towards the triangle.
Now. He's not a good thing. Now he's doing
a good thing. See how he's, you know,
I see. You got to tap once from
an arm bar from that position.
He got two on one on a guy's arm and then
extended it against is exhausting for
him though right now, right? It's Eric
silver or from Africa or if I'm at Brown.
Yeah, but Matt Brown was getting
bad. That was he. Yeah, he's tough.
He's tough. He's tough. Yup. The
UFC fighters. Pretty tough. Hey,
you calm down back there.
We've tracked up though.
He trapped this right arm that's dirty,
fucked up and I was going to take that
other handout. You've got it back.
This is very nerve wracking.
We've got two minutes left,
but she know what Matt Brown,
he relishes these kinds of fights.
Man Goes to the second round.
This is a lot of shit,
but Eric Silva tried several times to
exert a lot of energy to try to finish him
and what he's trying to trap that
arm again. You see how his heel,
his heels blocking his arm from coming
in and he's out. He's out. Oh boy.
Oh Shit. Here comes the Nissan.
Oh, there it goes. One of the body.
The body shot was great and there's an
elbow and another need of the body and
this is Eric's Silva.
He my God,
Matt,
Matt Brown has Robo is coming coming on,
man.
All that exertion. This is a kid
that wilted against John Fitch.
The same sort of scenario.
Brown does not stop coming.
This pace is got Brian. Keep making
comments versus guys in total wars.
Oh Man. Oh I'm sorry. I can't
help it. Huc Site. What?
These guys sweat a lot guys.
These guys are all muscle.
There's no fat on a minute and 20
seconds in my no bullshit aside.
This is crazy crazy.
The crowd. He's rugged,
rugged. This is exactly what I keep your
hands up, man. Keep your hands up. Please.
Fuck. Keep his hands up. Oh.
Oh, Eric Silva's in trouble. Don't
trip Silva's exhausted. Punch him.
Oh, good. Block of that name.
Took one to the head. Elbows.
That's about to break and my 45 fucking
seconds is a long time. We get beat on.
Ooh, that's more tied to,
that's that Muay Thai dump.
Oh Man. He's all over this. He
kicked him in the head kick. No,
Jesus Christ.
Last thing you want to see this?
This is fight fucking stopped on
a DQ. Oh Dude. Silva's exhausted.
Look at him walking away. Don't do that.
He can't even pick his legs up to hick.
Somebody calling out. It's crazy,
Matt Brown trout has. That's crazy.
Oh, that's crazy. For
your morale. Oh, cut.
Drags dues into hell, man. I
want it to get to. Oh boom. Wow.
Wow. Please let this fight. Keep going.
You guys didn't even better,
dude. He run down one does it
half rounds. Are you kidding?
Clearly give that round
to Matt. Right? Wow.
God Damn. Let me see
the replays that, wow,
this is a commercial for light.
Fuck nigger wearing a wig.
It's commercial thousand times
that came out like a banshee.
Arlo can play some ping pong.
He actually his peer legs on.
You haven't seen me play ping pong.
I'd actually kind of like Matt Brown and
Pink Pong is anybody like suffered less
from fucking their housekeeper and
getting her pregnant and then oral.
He's the greatest.
He went right into that to several chai.
I don't think I'm speaking actually ask
for enough loose some about that and he
goes like this. I go, what did you
do? And he goes, just laid low.
I swear to God. I go, what
did you do when that happened?
Because he was going to do a movie where
he has a Spanish lover and they said,
look, you know it's probably not a good
idea. And I go, what did you do with that?
I just laid low. Yeah, he is
a remarkable vision of what,
what's going on. It's kind of like
he's kind of a macho, he can't hear me.
Here's the replay. So this
is the gate. Oh my God.
And you see him tighten up.
Boom.
Brown is all over silver.
That's the thing about Matt Brown.
You can't blow your wad on
this motherfucker cause he
relishes. He'll look at us.
He relishes. Ward kept this pace. Two
and a half minutes, boys, come on,
you can make it so not brown. It's
fired it around and a half and you uh,
you,
you win the bet.
I don't think you're probably still was
going to wait to make it Silva's getting
fucking fuck stop. He's going to
have to hurt Matt Brown. I mean,
I'm assuming you can kick.
You need to take down.
You need to take, that's same. Kicky
fuck. Sato up with his last opponent.
Oh, both a little fatigued.
How could you not? Well,
I mean Matt Brown just
ate another liver kick.
He throws that whole,
Oh God,
this kid will drag you
in a fucking hell man.
Take him down short
elbows to got to love it.
He's got a really weird strength and
conditioning program to what does it feel
to five minute rounds like holding
a hundred pound ball. I got to get,
can I get my fucking kettlebells please?
You guys just got to get
the edit the address.
You write it down in that yellow
sheet workout equipment at home.
I'm getting a Matte Brown Tattoo.
I'll tell you that much.
What would a Mel Brown Tattoo be?
It's going to be,
it gets going to on my entire torso
and my back. Would it be him? Oh Man.
Oh, this dude is just shots.
Silver tried to trip him.
This could be it. How much more
time you need to admit it. I got it.
You need to take down for, I think the
kid might last a minute. Oh, I'm, I'm,
I'm feeling that you graze
the head all that hair.
Oh my God. He's all done.
Silva's tough though.
There's no way this kid's last in
five minutes. I'll tell you that.
I agree. He's exhausted and he's not
going to win and he's not going to last.
He just not going to at this point.
Look at that. Who? He's exhausted.
He's exhausted. The only thing
that's keeping them up right now,
his heart and will, does Sylvia have a
huge wake up call? Beauty is, yes he does.
Yes he does.
So he's a big guy.
I've seen him walk around outside the
octagon in between fights and I was like,
Geez. Nasty. Very nasty.
You Know Matt Brown's only upper
body workout he does for his arm. Oh,
he kicked him again. Delivered
Kick Matt Reynolds. He does.
He does dumbbell presses. And that's
it. By the way, silver can take off.
Oh,
his poor liver. Incredible. Well,
he might have a broken rib. I mean,
if he's getting hurt that easy.
Beautiful takedown inside controls.
Yeah,
man.
Damn mounted crucifix.
He better get an energy. Are you going
to stop the fight here but crucifix him.
Just keep that. Well, I'll tell you what,
Matt Brown also has a very good fucking
ground game to a lot of people don't
respect that ground game. His
ground games nasty. I got to,
I mean if he can step over this. Oh
No, no, no. Oh my God. Oh Man. Oh boy.
You attack the arm.
What do you call that?
The fuck out. Inverted
triangle. Yeah. Yeah.
That's a bad position for other
way though. That's, that's hell.
He needs to attack that. How is
silver breathing right now? He goes,
nope, he loves a wild fucking fight, man.
This is what I love about Matt
Brown fights. They're wild.
Did you never see a boring, oh,
he's done. The kids done. He just,
he can't, he can't defend. Look
at his left arm. It's like,
it's just floating around there.
He's not doing anything.
He's just hoping to get a break.
It's like a dark
dark from the mount, but
he's like, oh my goodness,
this is going to be it. Yeah. This kid's
not getting out of the mouth. Really.
Not leaving anything though. Yeah, but
Eric Silva doesn't have anything left.
Look good. You know, I love Herb
Dean in these situations because her,
look how closely and calmly herb Dean's
looking at this. He's not freaking out.
And I like how he took a knee so his legs
don't burn out like the Big Guy, Huh?
Oh,
oh,
holy shit.
Matt Brown is he locked up?
He locked up the triangle.
So I was in trouble.
How seleg he's attacking me
arm to keep attacking the arm.
The arm is the shit, but he also needs to
hook that leg that, you know he'd been,
that leg is important.
Oh my God.
It's fucking hard coming up.
If you had bet,
if you had bit the over for two rounds,
you'd be having a goddamn
heart attack right now on
that is going can get us back
for them to this round. Nope.
20 seconds is fucking fight is incredible.
Just needs to attack the body.
I feel sorry for the people that are
watching us online that are 15 seconds
behind
cause we're like, we're talking, I
mean one of the fight could be over.
This is pause your DVR.
You fucks. Stay with us.
My 15 second talk about a
main of wow being inspired.
What are we doing?
I got to go.
Oh my God. This is incredible. What
a fucking fight for our best fight.
I remember saying,
Hey Michael Bisbing eye.
Let's go back to this cause we're maturing
rounds. Um, it's good. Is it all right?
Is it all right? Yeah. Yeah. Damn Dude.
Maybe the worst.
Don't ever try to go in an acting
role when we're smart and good.
Did it seem good? It's like
one of them is dark. Yeah.
He's looking at me like, let's not talk
about this. All right. I'll let this go.
I'm going to, yeah. He wouldn't ask if I
asked him. He wouldn't tell me. You know.
When are you going to do, he's a tough
motherfucker. He's having problems too.
He's got a weak arm.
Really? Same thing. Yeah.
Pinched nerves here on your boy here on
the same issue. I know I haven't wrote,
well I wrote with you on last week
for the first time in about six months
because he's had a neck issue. Yeah.
How's he doing now? Is he better? Yeah.
What did he do to get better?
He saw some specialists in Beverly Hills.
Oh yeah. What the guy
tell him? I'm not sure
what a fucking fight this is so far.
I want to see that dig into the body.
There it is. Out of nowhere.
He heard them. I mean Matt
Brown was coming on strong.
Here we go. Round three bitches
throw to the body. This is a,
this is a matter of whether or not Eric
Silva has that second wind in them.
You know, these mother fuckers that
caught all this incredible weight,
it catches up with the right [inaudible]
in this kind of a fight because Matt
Brown is not a big guy.
He's not cutting a shit ton of weight.
He's not a 200 pound roll.
Oh Man.
He's just breaking motherfuckers
piss break in her way.
Oh God, this is awesome. Oh,
spinning back fist and he's just
constantly on you. You never get a break.
There's no rest. There's no break, no
risk. Your heart rate's consequently
would fucking love to see
fight Matt Brown, Nick Diaz.
I think that might be the greatest
fight in the history of the universe.
You might be really back,
oh my God,
Matt Brown versus Nick Diaz might be the
greatest match up of all the holes that
go down. I don't know. I
don't know. Just chaos.
Just pure chaos. Well,
you know, Diaz is not,
he's not a guy that's gonna wilt
like Eric Silvis. I think this kid,
I think there's a lot of people that
do great and training and they do great
when they're not cutting the weight and
then they cut the weight and they think
they're going to be okay,
but they don't take into account that
diminished effect that it has on your
body. I mean, it has a big effect on
your body when you're in a war like this,
you really shouldn't be fighting a
fucking guy like this at 170 pounds.
You don't football games when it
gets to the overtime, when they go,
this is a war of nutrition,
not bitch for real.
They never say nutrition, nutrition,
nutrition. The pub we gave.
I gotcha. I gotcha. I hear you,
but this podcast, I'd probably let
that go if this wasn't on the Internet.
Browse on top of them. Fucking Eric
Silva. There's a cut now though.
Now they're going to look to stop.
That was mixing up. Where's the blood?
Eric's Elvis bleed. He's not,
he's not protecting himself.
Do you stop it now or now? Nope. No. Herb
Dean. We'll give them some chances, man.
He's pushing off a little
bit with his feet, his feet,
but that's it. That's Eddie.
He turtled up. He gave
up. Wow. Matt Brown.
Fuck you odds makers.
You pitches were wrong twice.
I'd make yourself look at and
look at that kind of chuckling.
Dell outfit was hell. It's good.
Look at Eric Silverman beaten down.
That motherfucker broke him.
Matt Brown is up.
He is a fucking beast. A great
fight. Holy Shit. That was fun.
Joe Silva doing it. He's in the
ring and he'd like to fight takes.
We know the facts. We know the secret
code was already making the next fights.
He's texting. Johnny has texting. He says,
listen to this podcast
idea robos to the eyeball.
He just elbowed him right in
the eye socket where the cut.
That's where the Kate Tim Silva
Silva game. Serious fight though.
Well he did in the first round,
but really the only thing he did
is that left kick to the body.
He just wiped blood off of his,
I took too much and you know it's just,
he's not in that league man.
He's just not in that league.
This guy isn't a hell league.
He dragged you into hell.
Hell member.
She looks just him.
He is rough as it gets.
He's been in there for a long time.
He knows what it feels like to being hell.
I'm just super,
I'm super impressed that he bounced
back from those herniated disc to not a
scratch on his face. You can go drink a
beer right now. It's five Kenny ever. Wow.
That was, took some shots to the liver
and he's the God damn. Do some core work.
Maybe help his discs. Help the body.
Well, I mean I'm sure he did something.
He has a very unique training regimen.
They were talking about it on my
message board. They were detailing it,
talking about some of the things he does.
It carries a barrel filled with water
like kill cause like you have to carry it
with your hips and he carries it for
five rounds and moves around with it.
It does a lot of crazy shit
level interesting shit.
All like hips and cores and glutes,
all bunch of things that uh,
his strength and conditioning
coaches some pretty Monday.
Monday you're going to
see on my Instagram,
me just carrying the big gas water bottle.
It's a copycat league.
You know what else works girls true
could carry girl heavy chair and even big
old heavy chair around the thing about
a barrel as he puts it on your hands
around. So what does he, I
don't understand. Hoist it up,
you know arches his back hips into it,
you're saying, right? Yeah, exactly.
You have to have your hips into it.
The same way you would take,
take a person down,
bad technique and I can get a hold
the pill or even defend a take down.
Who are these fucking jokers?
I'll tell you what,
these little skinny neck pitchers don't
know shit about MMA. Shut your mouth.
They probably made the odds. Jay and Dan,
did you make the odds? You fuck heads.
Why don't you go talk about
cricket? Talking about some
shit. You understand. So,
uh, I guess the podcast is over, right?
I mean this is bad. It's a good time.
I'm calling us to success.
I think this is a great,
probably the greatest idea
we've ever had collectively.
Come see me in the admin. Matt, look at
this. Eric Silva's still hasn't gotten up,
man. He's sitting, he's
exhausted, he's broken, and you
know when he announces he's,
he's realizing right now I'm
not going to be the champion.
Like I might be able to, you can't beat
that kind. Not going to beat that guy.
I'm not going to beat guys like him and
I'm not going to beat guys that can beat
him. Maybe it needs to fight 85 yeah,
well baby needs to stop lifting weights.
You know, this is the thing that dudes
have to realize. I look at Matt Brown,
not a big guy, man. He loved.
I wish I could give it some
bond. Give me some volume,
give it up campaigning for the
title a little early for that baby.
While he's one that man,
he's won eight in a row about that.
I would say I would definitely let,
let him fight for the title.
I mean Hendrix, right now, Johnny has
to recover from a torn bicep surgery.
This is the thing about the top of the
food chain. So if you're fighting Woodley,
if you're fighting Roy McDonald,
you're fighting Hendricks and
you've come forward like that,
you're going to take it down. You're
right. It's a different animal, right?
It's a total,
it's all about matchups
now him verse coils conduct. That's an
amazing fire. Carlos isn't shooting a AA.
Yeah,
but Carlos has got an ACL reconstruction.
He does going to be out for awhile.
I'm just saying there's certain guys,
there's the top three guys that the
very top are horrible matchups for him.
I don't know. But they wrestle
man. But here's the thing,
what if Woodley Beats Hendrickson,
the title Matt Brown Fights Woodley and
it gets into the fourth round. You know,
I agree. I'm thinking about
this motherfucker is, look,
I don't think there's a baddest man
on the planet anymore and it is.
I totally agree about matchups. I
totally agree. But this kid, man,
I'm telling Matt Brown might be as
fierce as anybody have ever seen fight as
anybody. And everybody was
saying that when he was in
the octagon, you know, like,
or rather when he was on the
ultimate fighter was said,
there was a thing about him. It
just, he breaks motherfuckers,
he breaks motherfuckers and I don't think
people realize another UFC fighter is
insane. Insane. Especially when the
ranked number 14 in the world. I mean,
think about the gritty guys you've seen.
Like he was man just over and over.
I mean out of all the guys
who have fought in the UFC,
who is fiercer me Vandelay
when he was in pride, right.
He's in pride is another level, but
he was also juice to the gills. It's,
that's why I meet another level.
It's a different thing to different
thing as having a real struggle time.
That bell all sorts of, yeah, that
kind of needs to learn how to tie,
but you can't give a belt if
you don't like, ah, fucking
granny knot. That's shit.
What are you fishing?
Tying up a boat to fuck.
It's all goofy in the back. Look at it.
It's all I ruined. The cockeyed shit
is boys. That's toss. Horrible. Horrible.
Imagine that you will go to your Fucking
Room when your dad tells you to go to
your room. Matt Brown, those kids,
they just watched him crazy
shit that they don't understand.
Like Jenny getting a serious fight.
Pure scared
eyes,
but plus genetics,
UFC active WinStreak John John 11 and,
and Barao seven Matt Brown. Seven. Wow.
Damn. Widen the sets. Impressive.
Oh, either differences.
Weidman never lost. John
Jones. Never Lost Hanan.
Barao never lost none of those
guys I've ever lost the RQ. Wow.
The last time I'm Matt loss was a
is in ski, which is pretty crazy.
He's, he's choking around. Yeah, they're
choking. Right. And you know, happy.
But I'm just saying after a war like that,
he's fine.
So right to he was completely
disrespected by the odds, you know?
And he's talked about it quite a bit in
the pre fight that it's two and a half
to one. And he was like, what the
fuck is that about man? He's like,
I've won six fucking fights in a row. And
you look at the quality of competition.
True.
And then you look at the guys that
Eric Silva fought and lost to Fitch and
knocked out by Don Young Kim.
Again, Don Young, Kim's up beast.
No doubt about it.
But how are you going to have
that kid losing to that guy?
Beating Sato and then coming off of
that fight being a two to one favorite.
That's crazy man. That
is weird. Super Weird.
Well in fights. Nice. Get him
right.
Fights is a success.
I'm going to quit the UFC and just do
this with you guys. Yeah, I'm done.
This is more fun.
It's way more fun to do it,
you know, just about as good as it
gets. But I think I found my future.
I don't like traveling guys.
I don't either.
No one likes [inaudible].
We just did this right from the comfort
of the podcast studio and the fucking
might've been my favorite
podcast of all time. Um,
I need a shit load of pickles, pickles. It
goes bulletproof coffee. You guys enjoy.
The wines were good. I enjoyed
every aspect of this. Look
at this as a stare down.
Here's the highlights again.
Eric Silva, Eric Silva,
and he heard him with that kick.
It's kind of a friend kiss. It's,
it's almost like a cocoon,
knows kicked that sort of
crossing kick did. He does,
but look all over him. Work in the
nic crank too much effort in that.
Yup, you're right. And he, he
gassed out because of that.
But I think it's also the body,
the body weight cut. I agree.
When I rented to Silva in Brazil, I swear
to God, the kid had to be 200 pounds.
If he's not 200 pounds, he's fucking
clothes. There's that cake again.
It's like a front kick butt at an angle.
It's how cocoons throws it.
It's like they call it a crescent kick,
but it's not a crescent kick because
it's a front kick because it's with the
ball of the foot.
I'll get you hooked him in the body there.
Probably same spot where you got
hurt before. It's a nasty inclusive.
Eric Silva was just overwhelmed
by the ferocity of Brett to do.
Just was never comfortable ever.
I'll tell you what I got.
I'm gonna say it right now.
Matt Brown was my favorite
fighter next to Brennan shop,
my favorite fight. I mean, not that
he's the best, but his fun is to watch.
He,
he just forces everything to be war.
You have no choice but to
be in the war. Yeah. No,
you're not going to sit back
and make it look pretty.
It doesn't matter who you are. When
you've signed them to fight Matt Brown,
you better get ready to have a crazy pace.
All the pretty shit's out the window.
You can be in the clinch
and be eaten body shots.
It's crazy to watch something like that.
Like he must've won a lot of fight of
the night bonuses. Oh, well if he didn't,
there's a fucking terrible
travesty. Amazing, amazing fights.
All right. Um, that's your chopper
shopper. They're picking us up.
Picking me up. I'm richest shit.
We'll be back tomorrow night.
We'll do it tomorrow night.
And then just wondering whatever
you are night with [inaudible].
We're going to talk about a flying
through the jungles of Peru.
I'm the top of feathered serpents.
He just got back from, uh,
yeah. From more trips. I hang out with
Gandalf, the white wizard for a week.
It's on, let's say. I like it real. Yeah,
it was. You just want to go eat somewhere.
It's 10 fucking steak. All right.
Uh, we're done. Ladies and gentlemen.
That's it.
Thanks to Onnit go to onnit.com o.
N n I t used a codeword Rogan save
10% off any and all supplements.
Anything tell people about on it and
think crazy. Anything going on? Nah,
everything's good. New Shit coming
out. Oh, the Onnit academy is awesome.
We really consolidating
all the unconventional
workouts and stuff like that.
So go to on it. Click on the academy ton
of Info, Macy's clubs about, you know,
we got a new suspension training system.
We've got all kinds of shit.
Then come Alpha brain.
Fuck yeah man.
We got some writing addresses people
and we got a kettle bell for your ass
coming out soon to the motherfucker
vol kettlebells coming out.
Wait till you see this one.
Say a word.
How much time do you think
before that comes out? The
last one I showed you. Yeah,
that'll be six months.
Six months from now,
your Dick will be hard as steel and
you'll be so excited to get this.
But Mack Brown,
Dick will be harder than Rogan
eaten that stuff from GNC 10 years ago.
10 between now and then they'll please
get in shape so you can use this bucket
for Brian. You're not ready for
this. I don't know about that.
You're not ready for that one. Kind of
a how big of a Kettlebell he's, I mean,
I don't know man. I don't want, I'm
not telling you about with Kettlebell.
Betty could pull a 70 pound ball
without having a fucking hernia. Yeah,
he's a 90 pound boat. But you
struggled with the 60. I wasn't,
I don't have the video on that.
I'm not sure about that.
I was worried he's going to
shoot in my neighbor's yard pass.
Guys. I had done, I had hit my
back that day, so I didn't want to,
I didn't want to hurt Jihad to herniate
my bag all right. Tomorrow. And uh,
we got a fucking crazy week
coming up. Um, we got, uh,
I think you say his name. Jank Jank Ugur
you're from a young Turks. Great Guy.
He'll be here on Monday.
Tuesday. We're doing, um,
hopefully if will work at the times.
We, uh, had a change of times a bit,
but Doug's Stan hope will definitely
be here. And Tom Rhodes as well.
Wednesday we're doing the
tripod cast, which is, um, uh,
Duncan Trussell and
Chris Ryan. Uh, Thursday,
Randall Carlson. Friday, Rhonda
Patrick, kind of a lot of shit happened.
Ladies and gentlemen, Ilana
fucking Shit. But tomorrow,
tomorrow we talk about Gandalf,
we talk about Peru,
talking about the white wizard.
All right. We love you guys.
Thanks for tuning in and thanks for
being a part of the very first ever,
what do we call this thing?
The fight companion podcast.
That's what I'm calling it. [inaudible]
fight squad podcast, whatever it is,
whatever it called, rat pack. That's
it. That's it. Much like that.